uh open up the hearing on HB 485
establishing Deputy Animal Control
Officers and we'll recognize our first
Speaker I assume representative
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm sorry I've was reminded of
one thing I forgot again
Mr Clark
uh Vice chairman power here
representative Guthrie
Clark's here representative lasalles
here
representative yokella
representative Elwood president
representative Brown
representative Cahill here
representative
here
representative here representative
Gilman here represents majority here
representative mangaputi
here representative Gallagher
here
representative Hicks here representative
Holland here and representative priests
okay representative control
thank you Mr chair again and thank you
members of the committee
um I have brought forth an amendment to
the original bill
um I'm hope that everyone has that in
and the it's an act requiring a deputy
sheriff to to be appointed as an animal
cruelty investigator is what the title
says but technically all we're asking
for is that one person in the Sheriff's
Department
take a course
and be trained in animal cruelty
and yes they would be the point person
if the sheriff's department chose to do
be part of an animal cruelty
investigation but it is not mandatory
the key thing here is the second section
where it says that all municipalities in
the county shall notify
the animal cruelty investigator at the
Sheriff's Office of any case involving
cruelty or violence against animals
right now we have no reporting
mechanisms to understand how many
cruelty cases are going on in this state
and I think this would be a step forward
there are 83 towns and cities and
municipalities that actually have Animal
Control Officers
the other over 250 do not
this past summer
one of my constituents made a complaint
about some horses that were being
their only course of action was to call
the police department who absolutely had
no idea what they were looking at or
understood
what a sick animal looks like as one
person will tell you I mean our my own
Sheriff has said I can look at a cow and
I think they're all sick so
he would not be a good person to be
looking at animals
but if we had someone trained in this
and we had somewhere where the local and
law enforcement could go to for a
resource or ask a question
what happened was is these horses
as you all know we had some pretty hot
temperatures this past summer well over
the 90s
I had a person who is has known grown up
with horses all her life complaining and
complaining and complaining and finally
she called me because she didn't feel
like she was getting anywhere she called
the state vet's office she called the
Department of Agriculture she called the
local law enforcement finally
local law enforcement
made an appointment to go out and see
they also schedule an appointment with
the state facts
to come out and look at the animals
well in the meantime between law
enforcement and the state vet
appointment
they move the horses to another area
that they thought they could stay in and
they in the local law enforcement said
you know what this issue is resolved two
days later
and they canceled the state vets
appointment two days later those horses
it took another two weeks before the
state vet's office could get out there
because of the canceled appointment
I talked to the sheriff he goes there's
the local police department did what
they thought was best and they were
trying to do what was right for the
animals but they did not do not
understand the laws for animal cruelty
they do not do not understand what to
look for
I'm not talking about putting an animal
control officer at the sheriff's
department I don't want them going after
stray dogs and this that and the other
thing we're talking cruelty there aren't
that many cruelty cases in this state
every year
well there are a lot more than there
should be
but the number is manageable but if we
had someone as a resource
for those 250 plus towns
cities municipalities
some of these things might not fall
through the cracks the other thing is is
the reporting mechanism here
is really important we need to
understand what we're looking at we
can't fix a problem that we can't
quantify
thank you representatives are there any
questions I see lots of questions
representative let's start down that end
representative priest thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question what do you envision this
training to be and how long and it would
take to get the officer up to speed
about what to look for for cruelty in
animals
uh thank you representative priest for
uh the question
um the commission the governor's
Commission on the Humane treatment of
animals they are working on with police
standards on some of that it's probably
a two-week course so it's not a ton of
time invested but the key with the
sheriff's department is they actually
are deputized
so which is different we're an animal
control officer is not so that's why we
don't they can really go get involved
representative yukela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
so
it seems like your testimony is that
there is currently no
no
um
no training available that they're
developing it currently and so
it's so we're not sure of the voluntary
once the training is available the
voluntary
um attendance at such training
um so is
um do you think that this is
um the right time for a mandate that
they go to that training
um
uh thank you for the question
representative yokella
um so I can tell you that in January
there were two separate Fridays where
there was online training uh one dealing
with the legal portion of it and the
other one dealing with enforcement so
there is training that has been
developed and at one time it was being
taught but it's not mandatory uh
currently
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um rsa6 what did I say six
forty four eight Roman 4 A1 as we go
through the all the subsections there's
just one phrase in there when it comes
to cruelty to animals where it says an
animal confiscated by the arresting
officer so I assume if there's a problem
in my town I call the police department
because I think there's an issue there's
an arresting officer who follows the
statute I just I'm curious about the uh
the working relationship between this
person and and that arresting officer
can you help me understand what that
would be or if any uh thank you for the
question representative the reason we it
was the original Bill there was some
confusion and there seemed to be a lot
of people weren't happy with it because
it was stepping on toes
this doesn't say that the sheriff's
department has to be involved they the
local arresting officer can ask the
sheriff's department to get involved but
it's not mandatory okay
um so last term we had a bill about
Animal Control Officers
um about a case of
there is a town with an elected Animal
control officer Danville specifically
and that hearing um
revealed to us that apparently there are
um in some towns some there's some
confusion about the separation of Duties
between Animal Control Officers and
the police departments and I'm wondering
if could you tell us a bit about how
exactly this bill
might affect that
uh thank you for your question
representative Gallagher this does not
have anything to do with municipalities
this is only a tool if the
municipalities so choose and if the
sheriff's department deems they will
have a relationship with local law
enforcement or the local animal control
officer if they deem that it is
necessary for them to step in they can
choose too and as I said the animal
cruelty investigator at the sheriff's
department would be deputized so if they
had to arrest or issue things that
something separate most Animal Control
offices are not deputized and cannot do
that
um representative Manchester Puti
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question I
have two-part question one is the
amendment completely replaces the
original bill
including the title correct
and secondly the training that you're
talking about does it exist in one form
or the other in the state or outside
around other states that is specific to
thank you for the questions
representment so one yes this replaces
the original Bill there was some
discussion in some angst on the part of
sheriffs and local law enforcement and
Animal Control Officers in the original
Bill thus the the amendment brought
forth
as far as the training I know there has
been training in the state
at the police standards and I believe
it's trying to be implemented again
um I think with this coming forward it
representative treeleven
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question representative
I chatted with uh one of your
co-sponsors before the hearing today and
I asked him and I'm just going to ask
you the same thing this person who's
going to be deputized will this be the
only thing they do in the sheriff's
department or will they have other
duties not deputized trained excuse me I
use the wrong word thank you for the
question representative uh no they would
just be trained in this thank you
representative service
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question my question has to do with the
last sentence in the amendment lines 12
and 13 where it says all municipalities
in the county shall notify the animal
cruelty investigator of any cases
involving animal cruelty or violence
against animals
exactly what that means what are the
reporting requirements because it's not
a May it's a shall so what's what is the
mechanism here and how is it enforceable
thank you for the question
representative Davis right now there are
no reporting that people are supposed to
report into and I don't know the name of
the database it's not happening
okay so we're trying to get a handle on
what's actually going on in this state
and there is a difference between a
um and I think
cruelty is defined somewhere in statute
um and I don't know the the RSA number
off the top of my head and I think so
this would just give each County one
place to report to instead of reporting
to you know this place in this place and
that way we would be able to handle and
get an idea of what's going on in our
state and where the issues are because
I'm not sure if everyone under
understands animal cruelty isn't always
cruelty it's you could is attributed
sometimes to mental health issues for
and that's how a lot of these animal
cruelty cases come about is because of
representative Keller
thank you thank you for taking the
question so I have
um I'll have a number of them but the uh
is it your testimony today that there is
some training which has been approved by
the police that is currently approved by
the police standards and training uh
Council relative to Alamo quality as
required by your bill
thank you for the question representing
your color and I want to say yes but I'm
not positive and I will double check
into that I know there was training like
I said I was invited to the online
training this past January there were
two Fridays that it was done there is
the person uh so I know that it was
there was training at one point at the
one follow-up representative yokella
it's actually a new question
um the the uh
as far as the uh enforcement what if
what if no one actually takes the
training then
nothing happens so so it's voluntary
training now and since there's no
enforcement mechanism in this it would
also essentially be voluntary after this
passage of this bill
thank you for the question yes there is
representative uh Caleb
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
clarify here you're saying this is a
voluntary program but I'm seeing right
here in the language of the bill in line
9 the sheriff shall appoint a deputy
officer and I'm also seeing shall be
required to complete the training so if
it's voluntary shouldn't the language be
May okay thank you for the question
representative Cahill and I think what I
was trying to say to representative
yokella was even though the RSA that we
were trying to pass says shall there is
no enforcement mechanism or no penalty
if they don't
I think that was the question that he
so technically if they didn't follow
what we did they would not be following
one final question representative Kelly
go ahead thank you thank you for the
question or for taking the question
um
um if
this law came into effect 60 days
after passage
um
would
all of the sh if and the um training is
not currently available or even if it
was currently available
um would everyone all of this this
training need to happen and the
appointment need to happen prior to the
enactment of the bill or is there some
time frame that you're thinking between
the enactment of the bill and some
you know Judgment of you know this this
sheriff is not following the law
thank you for the question
um so
upon the passage of the bill
the deputy the sheriff would have to
appoint someone they would have to
appoint someone
or designate someone to be the animal
cruelty investigator in that office
and that person it doesn't say that they
have to complete the training in 60 days
it just says shall be required to
complete in-person training
so
yes
okay thank you for your test what thank
you for your testimony we have a very
long list of speakers and uh the
chairman has once again underestimated
the time for this bill so
um thank you representative Compton we
have a bunch of speakers anybody who
intends to speak on the pink cards
strict three minute limit uh when you
see Vice chairman power hold up the card
that means you have 30 seconds to go
we'd ask that you'd be brief uh
non-repetitive and uh so we can get
through this hearing thank you next we'd
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Peter Bixby uh Stratford
District 613 Dover and uh I will be
fairly brief I think that representative
covered uh the the meat of the issue
um
a couple of things that uh I'd like to
add to what she said it's important to
recognize that the State Department of
Agriculture does not have any
enforcement capacity for animal cruelty
cases the enforcement capacity is all
with local law enforcement and uh it's
uh when you have a small town that has a
very small Police Department
it's it's unlikely that there are going
to be people who are trained in this
specific uh aspect of law because it
doesn't come up very often there are a
small number of animal cruelty cases uh
each year uh and they tend to happen in
Fairly disparate places so there's not
likely to be much experience in the
department and dealing with it so having
someone at the county level who uh
understands how the animal cruelty
statute works and how uh how these cases
go about and what needs to be considered
for them isn't it would be a very
important resource I
um discussed this uh briefly when we
were proposing the bill last uh last
fall with uh Sheriff Brave in Stratford
County and he said he thought that he
thought this was a really good idea that
it's something that he would be happy to
have his department on do as a support
for the municipalities uh another uh
there was a question about training one
aspect of that training is there there's
a Governor's Council on the Humane
treatment of animals which has produced
as an extensive guidebook on how uh the
animal cruelty laws work and how they
need to be uh and how they can how they
would be
um executed and that guidebook is
available for police training
um I I assume that that's something that
is used by the police training and
standards uh in their course for
officers
um
another thing to that's important to
um emphasize is that most of the animal
cruelty cases in the state are a matter
of neglect and it can stem from mental
illness people with hoarding disorders
it can stem from people who think
they're doing the right thing for
animals and uh but don't realize what
they've gotten into and end up uh not
realizing that they are mistreating The
Animals by not providing what the
animals need
there are very few cases of active uh
choices to hurt animals but there are a
number of people who are not uh who
don't realize that what they're doing
isn't in the best interest of the
animals and having someone in the county
who officers can use as a resource to
figure out how to go about dealing with
that is would be a great Advantage for
the animal population in the state and
for the animal owners in the state and
I'll I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you representative Bixby
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned
um there's
cases in the state do you have actually
a number of cases of cruelty to animals
I I don't have the current statistics
and one of the things that uh this bill
will do will is actually make it
possible to establish those statistics
more firmly I know that uh in the course
of my uh term on environment and
agriculture we have had a number of
bills come forward in order to improve
our animal cruelty laws which we have
been gradually working on uh and
uh some of these cases have been very
high profile like the one in Wolfeboro
uh there is also one um and I'm
forgetting one of the towns near between
Peterborough and yeah and Keane I don't
remember I mean quit which one it was
right right now but cases involving you
know uh between 25 and 100 animals who
are not being well cared for uh those
were high profile ones there are other
ones I'm sure the State Vet can you know
has a list of ones that he's been called
in on but uh it is something that
happens regularly but not uh in vast
numbers
representative of your color
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
you said that there's
um not a lot of these cases in this
state
um so why choose that the um the
training that be shifted to the county
level instead of just having a go-to
person at the State Police level and
um and uh have that be this the point
person because the uh law indicates that
the uh enforcement of these statutes
happens at the municipal level
so there needs to be the municipalities
representative yakella one follow-up
please thank you
since the since the um the enforcement
is happening at the at the uh Municipal
level and this person is just going to
be a resource wouldn't that resource
also be available if that person was at
the State uh police level
and
um
I'm not sure well I'm not entirely sure
why the sponsor chose to that that
wouldn't be a question for
representative in terms of why she chose
the uh the county level rather than the
state level but my my inclination and I
would if if I were the prime sponsor on
this I would have done a little bit more
research in terms of that but what I
what I didn't do what I did do in terms
of research was I spoke with uh my local
sheriff and uh he said this is something
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in today's newspaper where I live in
Lebanon there's a very long story about
a case of animal neglect and cruelty
where people called office after office
after office and we're told we're not
responsible we're not responsible we're
not responsible even though the title of
those offices was prevention of animal
cruelty
do you see a similar kind of round-robin
situation happening in New Hampshire and
is that one of the reasons that this
bill was brought forth
yes uh the the the capacity to have uh
one designated resource in the county
that can work with both local law
enforcement to help them do things
correctly would really help in a lot of
animal cruelty cases uh because the
local officers are doing a lot of
different things and being trained in
this is pretty low on their list because
it only comes up once you know in a in a
given Community it might not come up for
you know like 20 or 30 years in a row I
it it so there's not a base of of
experience at if there's someone at the
county level it does come up you know
more frequently in in counties than in
specific towns just because of
probabilities so that person would also
be able to have a broader range of
experience
oh follow up
thank you Mr chair
um
in the process of of putting the bill
together was the sheriff's Association
consulted and and how are they are they
comfortable with the words shall I'm
going to interrupt um we have our next
speaker will be from the sheriff's
Association so we'll hold that question
okay well I'm glad that I I was going to
say I don't know so
um that's uh easily solved thank you
Senator Manchester
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Bixby for taking my
question my question is you talked about
large-scale high-profile animal cruelty
cases but does this address at an
individual level more and more people
have animals for their emotional seeing
eye guiding you know for so many things
would this address in those situation if
the animal cruelty or neglect exists it
it would it would be a an available
resource for any sort of animal cruelty
uh and
uh just to be clear
almost all animal owners in the state of
New Hampshire treat their animals well
it is a rare thing that something that
when it goes awry and uh but uh when it
does go awry it is the duty of the local
police to be the first uh people to look
at it and they often need help
thank you representative Bixby thank you
for your testimony I'm going to call the
next uh testifier Elizabeth Sergeant New
I also forgot to mention when you do
come up to speak uh please State whether
you're for or against at the beginning
because we have a few pink cards that
have
don't say either
hi good morning chairman members of the
committee my name is Elizabeth Sargent I
work for the infinity Capital group here
in Concord I'm here today representing
the New Hampshire Sheriff's Association
I did not intend to speak on this bill
today I was going to be listening taking
some notes and getting back to them with
where representative was headed I did
not have an opportunity to speak with
her the sheriff's Association I do know
that I was just told the sheriff Wright
did see this amendment the sheriff's
Association in total they just haven't
seen the amendment so I can't comment on
it I'm happy to take back any concerns I
know I received a florea female from
several of the 10 high sheriffs that
they did have concerns about this bill
they do have the invest The Authority
they can investigate these cases now
they normally act as a resource for the
local police departments and I will add
I also represent the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police they
were watching this bill they did not
weigh in they thought it was going to be
a county bill well so we do have some
questions I probably don't know the
answers but I'm happy to take all of
this information back I'll get the
amendment from representative com toy
and I will get back to the committee
they did have some initial concerns for
your testimony representative priests
thank you Mr chairman one of the
concerns that I have is again it's the
training and I really don't see the
problem you know in training the
officers to see the cruelty so sure I
would love to have their input on that
yeah I just emailed the director at
police standards and training and to ask
him if there is training in place so I
think that's one of the questions we
representative you occult yes another
question I I would like
um some some feedback on is if they have
concerns about the shifting of the cost
of this to the to the um local uh or the
uh county level in where it may be able
to be handled at the state level in the
state bear bear the cost of that
training so a couple of the responses I
did receive from sheriffs did mention
that cost could be a concern yes thank
you
thank you for your testimony thank you I
look forward to the information sure uh
sure guys stand up
my name is Nancy Holmes and I'm here
today from New Boston New Hampshire
could you do me a favor and pull that
mic closer to you oh sure I think
okay I'll start over again my name's
Nancy Holmes I'm here today from New
Boston New Hampshire and why overall
support the concept of this bill I have
a problem with one small part of it
which I don't think anybody's going to
much like because it would expand the
cost
but I looked at this bill and I thought
you're putting all of this on one person
within the sheriff's department one
Deputy one person is not always
available
you know does this mean people are going
to have to wait days or weeks or
whatever while somebody comes back from
doing whatever they are doing
to be available to be that resource
the other side of it is is animal
cruelty investigation is extremely
stressful
people who tend to take on that role
like animals and dealing with the things
that people do to animals whether it be
out of the neglect or on purpose say
with dog fighting those kind of things
you know they can take a toll on a
person
assigning only one person to be the
trained person to understand the the
issues and to handle all the input
coming in maybe from different towns
within the county I think is overdoing
it I think one is not enough
and if you want to have have the
sheriff's department be a resource this
should be more than one person maybe
even all the deputies are able to share
the burden and allow the person
who is dealing with whatever cruelty
case it is to have some peer support in
you know in their job and handling this
kind of thing I know that law
enforcement often deals with stressful
situations but I think adding one more
and saying oh just you you are the one
who are going to have to do that and one
of the reasons I thought this is uh I
worked for a very large bank and I
became the alternate one person to
handle any major issues with their
computer systems unfortunately the
person who is the main person became
immediately unavailable after five
o'clock every night so I was on call
nights weekends vacations you know out
sick did not matter I was the person and
it's very stressful to be in that role
and have all the responsibilities stuck
on you
um and I I really do believe that even
though training is costly there's always
an advantage to have better trained law
enforcement personnel and I think that
expanding the training to more than one
person Per County would be better the
and I know there's been a lot of
discussion about whether it would be
good at the state level versus at the
county level I'm thinking the county
level people would have a better grasp
on what's going on in their County the
players in the different towns and the
police forces and so on this damn sure
the states police could do this but I'm
I think the county level
um just might add extra insight into the
any issues that come up be happy to take
any questions
thank you for your testimony
representative Gallagher
um so just to be clear
so is this
testimony
the the Rand testimony says Ash written
but there's an amendment here so are you
speaking to the bill s ridden or the
amendment of it as it turned out the um
bills kept that one person in the
amendment so I got to glance through the
amendment rapidly and I saw yep still
got one person that the county level is
going to be responsible for this and uh
you know I I think that's um I think
that's pushing it you really need more
than one resource thank you
so you know further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you for
thank you Mr chair Nate Grace for the
municipal Association I uh we don't have
a position on the original bill
um I saw the amendment this morning and
I just wanted to comment
um that we are concerned that the
amendment the last line of that about
municipalities would place the burden on
municipalities
my preference would be the last line of
the original bill which places the
burden on the county
um and I know that the county sheriffs
will object to that I don't have to
consult them on it
um but uh realistically I think the last
line of the original Bill uh details
kind of the role of of what
um the the relative parties will do here
a little bit better in addition to
placing the burden on someone other than
who I represent
um but that also clarifies what the role
is there rather than
having the potential as Representatives
Davis said of you know having having uh
persons notified who would presumably be
in charge of doing these type of
Investigations but maybe not providing
that that same support it provides a
clear Mandate of here you're if you're
going to get this training you're also
going to be responsible for doing this
kind of Investigation in this type of
type of offense
um and and one other thing to highlight
is
um the last line of the amendment isn't
quite clear on when municipalities
should report to uh the county what's
what's happening if it's after charges
are brought that could be under the
animal cruelty statute RSA 644 colon 8
which would either be a misdemeanor that
would presumably be handled at the The
Local District Court so by the local
police department or a felony which has
already held handled by the county
attorney's office so there's kind of a
built-in bill built-in notification
there but they're a whole number a whole
list of other
animal related offenses under RSA
chapter 644 colon 8 and I'm not going to
list those because it's like 20 offenses
happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony seeing no
questions thank you called final uh
speaker Kurt Ehrenberg
and Mr Ehrenberg when you start could
you please say whether you're for or
against you did not mark it off I'm
sorry my name is Kurt Ehrenberg I'm in
favor of the bill I'm the state director
of the Humane Society of the United
States
I also serve on the governor's
Commission on the Humane treatment of
animals though I'm not here to represent
that body
um
there's been plenty said in questions
we believe that there is a need for more
scrutiny in this state particularly in
more rural
less
well-served by law enforcement areas
in the state for more
attention to be paid to animal cruelty
um
this goes
some ways to addressing that issue
so we do support that and I'm happy to
thanks for your testimony uh
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
does this bill go far enough in other
words
um
to include a reporting requirement or
mandate you know regulations that govern
how
this is going to work well I've learned
something I've learned is I would do not
want the perfect to be the enemy of the
good here this bill goes a long way in
creating a
one person in each County who by the way
in terms of training I think it's
explicit in the amendment that the it is
a deputy sheriff
so they're already fully trained in law
enforcement to be a deputy sheriff in
that in the state of New Hampshire
in terms of training for sorry to get
sidetracked but I think this is
important training for
animal cruelty investigations there are
trainings that could be Avail available
my organization Humane Society the
United States offers Law Enforcement
Training
what I'm saying is there is readily
available uh not that complicated
uh could certainly spell it out
somewhere
um so dance and I'm sorry I got
sidetracked
if you wanted to continue or get back to
where we gives me representative state
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
my concern has to do with how this bill
might
contradict existing law in New Hampshire
which currently says
that
complaints pertaining to the abuse of
animals shall initially be filed with
the local law enforcement agency
and then it goes on to say at the
request of the local law enforcement
agency Animal control officer State
Police or Sheriff the state veterinarian
shall assist in a secondary capacity my
concern is that the language in the
amended version of the bill
directly contradicts what is in existing
law in terms of the order of reporting
representative stavis was that a
question
well do you do you share that concern I
I have not had that concern but I had
not it had not been brought to my
I don't believe that we run into an
issue here because
the intent of this if nothing else is
that the municipalities
would would be aware that there was some
oversight that they would be needing to
report anything and I would hope that it
would be
either amended or construed that
any cruelty case being investigated by a
municipality would be reported up to
this investigator so there was some
database there was some place where that
was being collected on the county level
which there is a need in this state for
more of this data collection
um
well no just to say there are cities and
towns that handle these cases extremely
well and there are places that need a
lot of help
thank you Mr chairman I'm over here
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the
fact that there are many towns smaller
towns and so forth that are in a greater
need than some of the larger cities that
we have
um
the focal point of the law seems to be
on the local municipalities
the fact of the matter is in a lot of
municipalities particularly in the North
Country there is no local law
enforcement the law enforcement is left
to the county
and how would and I'm I'm in favor of
this effort how would the fact that
there's no local law enforcement
uh
not being an expert
but having some knowledge of how it
works I think that we
we rely on the state police to be the
local law enforcement in city in the
towns where there aren't there are no
resources
I'm sorry this is in the way
um so it would be up to the state police
I guess to do that along with whatever
the governing body of the town would be
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman as the state
director for the
um for your organization you've seen the
number of cases of Cruelty in these
small towns how many of those go
I can't quantify that for you but I
believe that there are more than we
just the number probably
I I don't want to get into it it's it
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question my question is
during covet and the more animals were
adopted and then this you know has the
cases of abuse neglect
uh animal cruelty has it increased from
your uh perspective where it is your
Humane Society
you know it's probably in something I
should be able to answer I don't know I
thank you uh representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman I'm from up in
Wolf bro so I'm familiar with the great
Dame case
how would this proposed law make that a
so I was not in this position during
that period of time so I'm familiar with
it but I was not the state director at
the time just to say that
um
because
Chief Rondo and Wolfeboro is an
exemplary uh example an example example
of uh law and how law enforcement should
act in these cases
um I wish you were here but I think what
he would tell you is that
he was surprised and under you know
totally overwhelmed by this for the case
and we'll we'll get into what that was
it was a number of great number of Great
Danes
um
and that this would have been a great
resource to him to have a someone he
could go to immediately with a uh this
law in place that would spell out that
this was the procedure
just to this small extent I think it
okay thank you for your testimony seeing
no more hands and no more pink cards
we will open up the hearing now on HB
636 relative to acquired education per
zoning board adjustment members and the
prime sponsor representative Cochran
who appears now to be o for two on
um representative Cahill could you
introduce the bill for us just simply
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
I'm here to introduce
house bill
636 FN relative to the required
education for Zoning Board of adjustment
members
thank you representative if I have one
pink card if the individual feels the
need to speak you may otherwise I'll
and with that I close the Herring on HB
.
um
next bill uh we'll open up the hearing
on HB 477 to prohibit Municipal
inspections of owner occupied units of
multi-unit housing
and I believe the
Prime sponsors here without a PIN card
make sure you fill one up yeah I will
okay
um good morning everyone I'm uh rossbury
represent Hillsboro 39 South Manchester
Hillsboro Hillsboro Manchester's Awards
689 30 000 constituents on Manchester's
South Side
um I bring together I bring you forward
a bill today I was trying to get an
amendment ready I ran out of time so I
do know this bill does need work so I'll
start off with that let me tell you the
problem I am trying to address I am the
owner of a duplex I live in one side I
rent the other makes me an owner
occupied piece of property with less
than four units
um I'm sure as you know units with four
or less are treated differently than
multi-families or apartments with five
or more by the uh by Hud and very
commonly in New Hampshire RSA one of the
things that the city of Manchester
requires if you're going to be a
landlord it's thing called a COC it's
certificate of compliance every three
years they come through and they inspect
your property that you're renting
um and the issue they charge you a 200
fee and they issue a certificate
basically saying this property is um is
good to rent uh I have my own personal
issues with that I'm not here to address
us the actual CLC structure itself today
but one of the things that did stun me
being a first-time landlord in the state
of man of New Hampshire in Manchester
was they insisted on inspecting the unit
that I live in and that that would to me
was a gross violation when the inspector
came and let me start by saying the
inspector was extraordinarily
professional he was very personal I have
no issues with the way he conducted
himself while he was there his name was
inspector Knight he was wonderful he was
doing something I have a philosophical
disagreement with but he did an
excellent job so this isn't about him
this isn't about his performance he did
he was very wonderful we actually talked
about me being a state rep for some time
but when I asked him uh why I understood
why he had to inspect the tenant side
that made sense right don't want to be a
slumlord but when I asked him why he had
to inspect my side he said something to
me that was very troubling and which was
what sponsored this idea which he said
well you could rent this side
um and the problem with that argument is
you could make that argument about
literally any piece of property in the
state of New Hampshire including
single-family homes
um so I'm not trying uh one of the one
of the ways this bill is structured
right now is it's basically prohibits
any inspection of any uh single-family
home or multi-unit that's not the design
the design is only owner occupied units
and I will put in a thing about
single-family homes but I'm going to try
to curtail it down to just for the
purposes of inspecting for the potential
of renting if the city wanted to inspect
my unit because I was going to rent it
totally fine with that that makes sense
right but the way housing is treated
four units or less are basically treated
the same as single-family homes so
there's this kind of loophole that I
believe the state should close down it
is very invasive when the government
comes into your house without really
cause I told totally would understand if
I didn't agree to the inspection of my
owner occupied unit that I wouldn't be
able to rent it out until it was
inspected I'm fine with that but there
are people that I represent who have
lived in their owner occupied units for
30 years and every three years the
government has to come in and tell them
that they could rent it if they wanted
to
so it's a gross invasion of privacy if
you live in a single family home this is
what I want you to imagine imagine if
every three years someone had to come
because the a inspector got to come into
your house and look through every closet
that you have go down in your basement
go up in your attic and inspect your
home on the potential that you could one
day rent it so that's the Gap that I'm
trying to close I unfortunately I was
trying to work on this over the weekend
but it turns out being a chairman of my
chairman and a business owner this
thing's runs out of the Wayside so if
the committee does itl because it's not
I will try to bring forth Amendment to
the committee at the committee itls it I
will bring it back next year I feel feel
that it is something that needs to be
addressed it is a gross invasion of
privacy to be told that because you live
in a multi-unit and you're a landlord
that they get to come in and look at
your inspection so with that I'm sure
representative
why is it not a gross invasion of
privacy to inspect the tenants buildings
I I philosophically agree with you I
don't know if there will be the
political will to end inspections of
Apartments I'm not here to address that
today I philosophically I agree with you
that's not what I'm trying to do if that
was a separate thing I would probably
sign on to it just as a matter of
personal property rights but that's not
what I'm here today to try to do
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Berry for coming to
testify before us
um I'm just wondering if you uh have any
safety concerns yep uh so I knew that
point would be raised um my Counterpoint
to you would be that you could make that
argument about any piece of property I
agree
um so if that is the case I guess my my
counter question to you is why aren't we
inspecting every single residential
piece of property every three years good
question
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking the question
um this is somewhat building off of
Representative true 11's question but in
the choice to rent
don't you also bear the responsibility
of making sure they're safe
which requires you to make sure your
attached dwelling is also safe it
doesn't negatively impact them yeah so
once again you can make that argument
any single family home if you have a
single family home that's next to
another single family home and that
other single family home catches fire
the the flaves could jump over and grab
that other house my point is you can
make that argument about anything in any
piece of property in this you can make
that argument about sheds that have
electricity running to them that are on
a neighbor's fence line so you kind of
go into the slippery slope there at some
point you do have a right to personal
property my point is that a man's home
is his castle and if they live in four
units or less which are treated as
effectively single-family homes we need
to respect that I didn't put it in there
for five or more units because those are
treated differently right the government
has always treated those differently I
guess a Converse argument I would make
is if you have those safety concerns as
a tenant rent from a unit went from a
building that has five or more units
those are held to higher standards
already
representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
is it your understanding that um or did
you consider the the opening up the
option for the tenant
to not have their
uh unit uh inspected as a part of this
bill or making that
inspection you know at the request of
the tenant instead of just you know the
government coming in and saying no
you're you're due
yeah it's actually something I did
consider
um I I tried to scope the bill down um
because I know kind of if you try to
tackle too much at once then it gives
people a reason to to knock things down
I did actually consider that um because
that would kind of almost be the Best of
Both Worlds as a tenant of well I feel
like my landlord's a slumlord and
they're not up to municipal or state
codes
um so I want this I want the municipal
to come in um the Counterpoint to that
in my head having been a so I went from
being a tenant to a landlord I didn't do
the like you know living my own property
transition I I just flipped
um one of the things that I could see as
a tenant would be you know it's
effectively like am I ratting out my
landlord and is that going to create an
adversarial relationship
um so I I didn't think about that it's
not in this bill just to be clear
um I did like have that kind of mental
exercise because it was worth having
um there's there's Plus or minuses right
the tenant should have a right to
privacy in my opinion
um you know in my in my leases it says
that I can enter the property with um I
have to give at least 24 hours note
notice unless there's an emergency
that's a pretty common cause I actually
had the very first people I run it to
were actually very good friends of mine
were like uh yo we don't want you coming
in with 24 hours notes we want three
days notice and I was like you know
that's fine as long as the pipe's not
bursting I don't really need to get in
there that quickly but yeah I think to
the some of the questions asked I think
tenants have a right to privacy as well
um you know as a landlord I have a right
to make sure that my property is not
being abused so like there's a balancing
act there
um but I you know for the same reason I
would I feel violated when the
government comes into my house to tell
me that I could rent it if I wanted to
uh I could totally see a tenant having
the same objection of being like yeah I
think my place is fine and I don't want
the government coming in but that's once
again that's not in this bill it's
definitely a philosophical conversation
I would have at tandy's though
foreign
representative Gallagher
so
um as a tenant who has
uh yearly inspections um so
um
my my
experience is generally with with the
inspections is generally that the
maintenance guy just comes by and asks
me if anything's wrong and leaves really
quickly and um doesn't yes there's a
question
um and and doesn't violate
um my privacy at all so do you
do you think it would be possible to say
just say
that
um
inspections should be in a way done in a
way that doesn't violate privacy rather
than
um rather than just outlawing them
entirely yeah so I think I think um the
representative maybe you may be a little
off base on what that sounds like an
inspection from your landlord's
maintenance inspector
um that's a landlord tenant issue this
is the city of Manchester sending a
government inspector into my home
um without honestly my consent once
again director Knight was wonderful was
very nice he was doing his job I'm not
after him
um it's just the the statement of well
you could rent it is a problem
um I lived before I moved into my place
I lived in a a apartment building I
think it had like 32 units or something
they came by once a year to inspect it
uh just as them but then I was there for
their COC inspection and it is more
thorough they go into the basement they
go into the attic you know they're
looking at wiring there's no you know
it's not you know knock on the door hey
is anything good here and then you know
it's it's not like that they are they
are in your stuff
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so in your testimony
you've referenced COC several times
could you define that
um and and part of my question after we
understand what that is when a a home or
a building in which people will inhabit
when it's newly constructed there's a
certificate of occupancy granted in
order for people to inhabit that
building how does that initial
certificate of occupants occupancy
differ from these
every three-year inspections so the COC
is our certificate of compliances
they're different from the certificate
of occupancies the certificate of
compliances these are these are not
annual but in new Manchester and it
differs by City Nashua has them as well
I would be stunned if conquer didn't
have them
um but they are they are inspections to
make sure that your property is livable
that are routine right so imagine if for
your certificate of occupancy right
imagine if every three years I don't
know what town you're from but a match
of every three years the town came
through to renew your Civic kit of
options occupancy in your house that's
effectively what they're doing to owner
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
representative for answering my question
um
would you have the same expectation of
requiring a building permit if you are
renovating your whole kitchen with new
appliances and new power needs and
um no um and I actually spoke with uh
somebody I forget was somebody from
Nashua and he raised this point and that
was actually why the bill does need a
mending this is not aimed at like
permitted new construction or anything
like that because at that point right
you're not like they've issued a permit
right we're showing up to make sure the
work was done by code right we're in a
different process right there's a level
of consent what we're talking about here
is every three years with no changes
right no perceived changes to the
property every three years the
government's coming in and looking at it
representative priest
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
um
it's my understanding that
that there is no reporting mechanisms in
the city of Manchester for once
for owner occupancy to change and to
become rental
you are not required to contact the city
and said I've been here a year and I'm
going to move elsewhere I'm going to
rent this they have no way of knowing
that
is this correct
um yes but to the point of your question
if the COC process changed right in
Manchester so let's say this bill
becomes law right
um and they can't inspect owner-occupied
units right but let's say as a landlord
I plan on moving out in the next year
and my coc's up I might say hey come and
inspect this so I can rent it right but
it's you know you don't make that
requirement of any single family home
right a person who owns a single family
home could move out and start renting
their property and by the way underneath
the city of Manchester's ordinance they
have to get a COC but there's no
notification requirement so that's a
problem for the city of Manchester
um but you have to understand that owner
occupied units are legally treated the
same as single-family homes for four
units or less right once they hit that
five five units there's too many people
living there there's a more compelling
State interest to to look at more
regularly but when you're talking about
four units or less we're not talking
about you know Mega you know Mega
property development companies we're
talking about these people like me right
you usually middle class people who are
trying to find a way to mitigate their
mortgage
that's my message to the committee is
you can make that argument every
argument you make you can make about a
single family home and that's the danger
what stops my Counterpoint to you is
what would stop the city of Manchester
from saying you could rent any single
family home in the city of Manchester
every three years we're inspecting every
house because you could move out of it
and you could rent it
thank you
follow up yeah right but it is true that
if you make if you're a single family
owner in Manchester you have to notify
the building department if you make any
substance
alterations to your building and they
have to inspect it correct you can't
just do you know that's my question yeah
correct but once again you can make that
argument about any single family home
and I'm not talking about people who
make permitted changes right if I want
to go and somehow turn my duplex into a
Triplex which I don't even know how I
would do um but if I do that I have to
go to the city I have to get a permit
right I'm now doing things that are kind
of outside the scope of you know me
living in my home undisturbed
thank you very much representative could
you turn your mic off there represent a
priest seeing no more questions I have
one question for you and that would be
you're talking about a potential
Amendment what would that Amendment
briefly include yep um so right now uh
the bill was closely to what I needed to
do um but right now it could be
interpreted um to the point about
alterations uh permanent alterations it
could be interpreted that you can make
permanent alterations and not have them
inspected so that needs to be tightened
up I need to make sure it's also in the
right section of RSA obviously I'm an
election law guy so this is this is a a
I have a lot to catch up with on this in
this section uh so that's what I'm
looking for and I do appreciate the
committee's indulgment on addressing
what I'm trying to address and not the
some semi-flawed language in this bill
okay thank you very much I will fill out
my pink card thank you very much
representative Barry seeing no more
questions I see no
more pink cards we will close the
hearing on this one after I announce
that on the blue sign up sheet there was
one individual signing up in favor and
with that we close the hearing on 477
wow believe it or not we are actually 15
minutes before our next
I think that's a first
so at 11 30 we will do our next hearing
foreign
okay welcome back everybody uh uh we are
going to open up the hearing on House
Bill 526 relative uh regulating the use
of temporary traffic control personnel
and we will recognize representative
Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um my name is representative David
Bickford for the record I'm here to
introduce HB 526
now the problem is that we have
qualified flaggers
that are being replaced by police
officers unnecessarily
at a much higher cost to the public
now this isn't a new issue that's come
up
um
part of the problem I think is because
some communities have created revolving
accounts and they can get money into the
revolving accounts if the police
officers work detail and they'll tell
the public well we can buy you a cruise
of this way or whatnot
um but still that's really no excuse to
be pushing people out of the way
and taking over their job these are
qualified flaggers it's no different
than having police come in and say to
the Walmart greeter and say you need to
step aside we're going to do your job at
I uh Came Upon
some of Jeb Bradley and Neil Kirk's work
then look into the issue and they came
forward with a study committee which is
what I brought before you
committee they did excuse me that was in
2015 and they did do a a bill after that
it went it's not in the Senate
um but they ended up tabling it then
and uh and so anyway I've gone back to
that I talked to his office and I was
able to dig up the final report and it
was interesting
and you all have that before you and
I've highlighted the section that's what
I think is pertinent anyway
and as you as you can see down at the
meeting summaries
Senator Bradley explained that this
topic had been brought forward to the
legislature on behalf of the Public
Utility Commission
the cost of using a flagger for the
utility company is approximately 25 per
hour while the cost of a police detail
is approximately 75 dollars per hour the
objective of the bill
is to reduce costs for utilities so that
they may pass on rate savings to
customers
so they had this little study committee
together and uh I don't know if any of
you remember Cordell Johnson
um I think it was actually John's ton
of the municipal
Association you see on page two I've
highlighted that he came forward with a
compromise language
and that's down at the bottom at the
recommendation I highlighted the
language and limit the use of police to
only one specific safety concerns occur
or if qualified flaggers are not
available
and that's what you see in the bill so I
brought that language forward from the
2015 study and I still think the issue
is more pertinent today than ever before
because the public sees this
and they see it as a form of corruption
despite the mafia coming in and telling
you you're going to step aside and if
the police are needed the bill allows
for that exception
but the public knows that qualify flag
is to be pushed aside unnecessarily
and this isn't a good time to be
uh continue with that image
now I had a number of people said they
plan on coming
the New Hampshire uh consumer Advocate
Don creese is the one that actually
encouraged me to file this bill he said
he would be over at the
um executive councils today and he tried
to get over here but otherwise he would
send in some written testimony people
from New Hampshire Electric Co-op asked
me to do this uh bill
so but as you can see behind me this is
why people are afraid to speak out
I guess I'm the exception but there's a
force behind me
that's going to tell you not to do this
you're going to hear about probably sex
offenders and things like that that are
involved with
flaggers
um that's that's what came up in the
last testimony during this study
um
of course it's really about money is
what it's all about
um so I think I've let me check my notes
I think I've touched on
most of the bases
um
yeah I just I just feel this is like
being in a third world country to see
this sort of thing going on we should be
ashamed
to see this and this is our opportunity
to
correct it
thank you thank you representative
Bickford uh before I open it up for
questions I just want to be clear on the
this that you handed out that was from
uh 2015. correct okay it's on it it's on
it says I saw that it said laws of 2015
so I'm just clarifying for myself to
make sure that this went down in 2015
which it appears it does but I'm just
clarifying for myself
uh yeah I think that's our only
indication right there okay and I assume
it may have happened it may have
happened in 16 you know where they they
created this
understudy I just for reference it
wasn't 2006 2020 it was around 2015.
yeah that's up that would be correct
okay and I assume you're open to
questions certainly representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question pertains
to the language on line five of the bill
where it states specific safety concerns
about the project could you define what
the criteria or explain what the
criteria is with regard to specific
safety concerns relative to a project
and perhaps give some examples I cannot
I really think it's a little bit vague
that language
okay uh and I'm worried about whether it
would be continually abused with that
kind of language in there but I think
I'm I'm sorry I can't answer that very
accurately
thank you representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so we all know that
the local police officers have training
in this in traffic control and safety
what kind of training will these
temporary people have
to do this work
they are all they are qualified flaggers
I was I was hoping some would said that
they would be here that does that sort
follow up
what what kind of training and where
does this training come from
I don't know
um
but when I talked to the New Hampshire
Cooperative they said that they they had
to be trained they cannot use anything
but trained people for their projects
representative Gallagher
um so I'm just looking
um
the uh front cover of the bill
um it has the committee listed as Eda on
here I'm wondering if this is this like
a second committee for the bill or um
did it get misassigned or could you tell
us what happened with there at all I
think that was an ERA
and then they realized it was more
appropriate to come to this committee
which I agree
I I didn't have anything to do with
actually I didn't even know this Bill
had come out
until I found it on the New Hampshire
Municipal association website for
clarification for the committee this
bill was vacated to our committee from
the
EDM executive departments and
administrative committee that's why
that's on the front of the bill I should
have mentioned that at the beginning
yeah so it's the only Bill within our
committee by the way that has been
vacated to us so I I don't know what
happened my neighbor my name never even
showed up in the calendar for the two
bills I filed
so I never had a chance to do any
uh amending or change it before it get
came to here but I think it's a good
language to start with
representative Keller
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
who decides is it the person
hiring the flagger or the town that
decides who what the specific safety
um in this case there is it would still
okay
seeing no further questions thank you
very much representative Bickford and we
will go on to other individuals who wish
to speak I have four pink cards I'm
going to remind those in the audience of
who intends to speak uh there was a
three-minute time limit please uh please
do not be repetitive I'm sure
the four of you who are going to speak
will have very similar testimony so if
it's been said don't reiterate it our
first person we will call up is Kyle
Daly
how many cars you say you have
we have four we need uh actually we had
five we had yours plus the other four
also when you introduce yourself make
sure you let us know if you're for or
uh my name is Kyle Daly and I strongly
oppose this bill
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Kyle Daly I've been a police
officer in the city of Manchester for
eight years I am the current president
of the Manchester police patrolman
Association and I'm on the board of
directors of the New Hampshire Police
Association both groups oppose
House Bill 526 over the next few minutes
I will give you examples of why we
wholeheartedly oppose this bill as it
relates to when a local law enforcement
officer shall be used during
um
projects that require traffic control
Personnel I will also provide a sample
statistic which was collected from
electric gas sewer and tree Crews
working in the city of Manchester on
February the 7th
if I could draw your attention to
January 19th of this year officer Daniel
Craig was working in construction detail
for liver utilities on Laurel Street in
the city of Manchester officer Craig had
been on his detail post since
approximately 7 A.M
when at about 5 pm he noticed a flagger
who was working the other end of the
construction zone running towards him
officer Craig was advised that a vehicle
had gone around the flagger struck the
flagger's vehicle and was heading
towards the Liberty Utilities crew which
was working on the roadway officer Craig
was able to get the driver to stop and
put the vehicle in park while speaking
with the operator officer Craig observed
signs of impairment and based upon his
roadside investigation officer Craig
placed the female operator under arrest
for operating under the influence of
liquor second offense in disobeying a
police officer
this was a case where a flagger clearly
had no visible presence in the roadway
no authority to be able to stop the
vehicle
and officer Craig's quick actions
subsequently stopped a two-time offender
from seriously hurting or maybe worse
killing a gas construction crew
this is just one example of how officers
take enforcement on uh on details
unfortunately I could go on for quite a
long time giving examples of vehicles
going around flaggers while in
construction zones but I won't waste
your time
in doing research for this bill I was
told this would help small tree trimming
outfits on the back roads of New
Hampshire save money
well I was able to speak with the owners
of two small family tree companies both
who work in the Manchester and the
greater area
the owners of both companies stated that
they would rather hire police officers
any day of the week
in that their financial savings is
minimal
next I spoke with gas electric cable
sewer and Sewer Crews that were working
in the city on February 7th
six electric Crews one cable crew two
tree trimming Crews two gas Crews and a
SuperCrew out of the 12 Crews 11 stated
they wanted flaggers sorry 11 stated
they wanted police officers over
flaggers at every job site the 12th
through did not care who was hired nine
of the 12 Crews stated that they have
witnessed a police officer working
working their detail taking enforcement
action while in the work Zone
they stated this ability for enforcement
often makes the work Zone safer
one tree crew stated a police officer
was not available he would rather put
his own employees in the roadway for
traffic control before hiring flaggers
this small sample size shows that more
than 91 percent of the time crews in the
roadway prefer police officers
conducting traffic control over flaggers
as a police officer we go through
stinging back stringent background
checks thousands of hours of training
and carry tools and ensure Public Safety
in the city of Manchester there are
eight registered sex offenders who list
a flagging company as their place of
employment
this is troublesome as Crews often move
around to different work areas not
knowing who their Flagger of the day is
it is very possible that a registered
sex offender could be working in your
neighborhood or even worse a school zone
in your town
yesterday I had the privilege of
speaking with the owner of a local
flagging company this individual agreed
that this bill does not make sense and
has potential negative impacts on both
sides this owner agree with me that if
it's not broke why fix it
the police officer versus Flagger
problem was addressed in 2018 and has
worked for both sides since then
finally I know most of you are fully
aware of the hiring and retention
challenges that state and just what
every city and town are facing in the
area of law enforcement passing this
bill will only add to that problem
recruitment of new police officers is at
a crisis Point everywhere the New
Hampshire State Police are currently
have around 70 open positions
this is serious taking away one of the
areas of work that many police officers
depend on will make recruitment
retention even more challenging
those of us in law enforcement love the
work we do
safety is our job and that's why I want
to urge you to defeat House Bill 526
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony going to
remind everybody try to keep it to three
minutes we were a little generous with
you on that one but if anybody in the
future please keep it to three minutes
do we have any questions representative
mandaputi
thank you Mr chair thank you officer for
taking my question
um
there are two parts to it one is having
the police officer as a flag for any
construction area but that isn't that uh
currently a local Municipal ordinance
where you know if it's a small job they
don't need to have but if it is cost
effective to have in a major job isn't
that the
current existing one where it gives the
people who are doing the construction
to either use officer or a flagger I
guess it comes down to local control of
the the town of the city
yes thank you Mr chairman and and thank
you for taking my question
uh you mentioned a little bit about the
uh
difficulties in retention with respect
to Police Department are you aware of
municipalities within New Hampshire that
are offering sign-on bonuses to get
police officers
I am
as a selectman in my town is there a
follow-up yes yes there is I'm sorry
follow-up apologize just a follow-up
as a selectman I can I can tell you that
it is the the police departments are in
uh significant pressure all along the
line and
would would it be your testimony that
passing this would be another
knife in the back of police departments
with respect to uh taking this away from
them
in my opinion I would say yes
um
you know I can't speak for everyone I
see other jurisdictions but the overtime
budgets for some agencies are greater or
smaller for others and this is just a
extra layer of financial means that
people can make and I use the boots on
the ground having a detail there is a
police officer for us in the city today
we have 22 details that are working so
God forbid something major ever happened
that's 22 extra police officers that
have a radio in their hand that could
immediately respond to something if that
occurred
thank you
uh representative Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question we on the municipal
and County government committee tend to
be a little geeky about these things so
bear with me this is my first time bear
with me as well please the
the horse
um
bringing forward legislation that would
give afari to authority to the municipal
governing body to adopt ordinances
regarding the use of flaggers
the law before us
would you say that that this law before
us does that or would you say that this
Law requires
that said municipalities do this because
a very big difference between enabling
legislation that's recommended in the
report and what's being suggested here I
get my question you're asking if this
Law requires
um companies to hire flaggers prior to
hiring police officers I'm asking if
this law requires municipalities to
for the questions
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm going to ask the
same question that I asked the prime and
that's
um regarding
characterizing specific safety concerns
about a project and um what does that
look like and could you give some
examples
well
excuse me I think you're going to hear
testimony after me uh safety concerns in
the city
um you know we as a city we there's
holes in the ground that would be a
safety concern that um we would have to
prevent
um
traffic from flowing down a certain
Street
um we hire many details in the city for
um marathons that require closing down
of intersections that it's my
understanding that flaggers cannot
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question
could it be characterized that
every
incident where you would need a flag or
would be a potential safety concern
thank you
um what is your understanding of the
current state of affairs of who decides
whether a flagger is allowed or not or
if a officer is required to so it comes
down each town or city as my
understanding thank you
uh representative Tatro you still have a
question yes
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your testimony
um
sometimes my years pick up things that
just stick there
and one was the statement that you made
response of the
way I understood it and correct me if
I'm wrong
to
if they had an emergency in the area
you would move those offices
to go to that
incident
what um what happens to the traffic
control for the construction company or
do they shut down
to my understand that they would be they
could be shut down depending on you know
what the incident may be or where they
follow up follow up
so what you're telling us is that
assigned to that
detail
are required someplace else
then
they're without flaggers I think that's
a I use that example but that's an
extreme measure that if a mass casualty
or mass event may happen that is just
for the boots on the ground most of the
times you're going to have your boots on
the ground of the community
on you know city streets and they're
there most jobs are we work in the city
are lengthy projects and you know same
officers take those jobs
you know every other week or every week
whatever it may be so they get to know
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking a second question so um with
regards to utilizing local law
enforcement for temporary traffic
control is that typically a a police
officer would be utilized that's on
schedule that day or would it be
somebody that was maybe not scheduled to
come in and work on that day but would
would come in to do that do you
understand the question yeah so I think
you're saying it would they be on shift
or required or would they be off shift
this is uh most details that members
work are uh off duty they're after hours
or they're on their days off I work
Monday through Friday so if I'm taking a
detail it has to be after hours or on
the weekends
so
follow up thank you Mr chairman so
therefore with that police officer they
would be they would be paid overtime is
that correct for that Duty we at the in
the city have a detail rate it's a
representative priest
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question do you know cases in
the state where they haven't used police
officers they just used
people they've
you know just temporary flaggers
and have there been any catastrophes
in the city that we have some details
that use flaggers during the day if a
police officer is not available to take
it
um
again there's you know instances all the
time that you know the people in the
public drive around uh flaggers they
they don't you know it's a safety
concern because they can't take any
enforcement action
um if they were to drive around me when
I'm on a detail I can legally stop them
pull them over like it would be a car
stop issue them a summons if need be or
just correct the driving behavior
um flaggers aren't able to do that
representative Albert
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
do you think that having the police
vehicles with their lights increases
safety along this absolutely one of the
tree companies specifically said a
cruiser on the back road is a lot safer
than having a flagger
okay see
representative yokella thank you
since these officers are off duty is the
use of police
um assets like the the cruiser allowed
during
um this these FL flagging opportunities
or for these officers that's up to the
um
don't quote me based on where they work
in the city or what is going on that day
they can request the cruiser as an
additional payment or additional money
they can request it for us in the city
so you get a police officer detail and
then you can if you need a cruiser our
crews are specified depending on the
roadway that's when a cruiser can be
brought in
seeing no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony we'll call Mike
uh
I was going to say good morning but
we're almost at noon right now so I will
still say good morning
my name is Mark bodoin and I'm opposed
to this legislation
I'm a retired detective sergeant from
the New Hampshire State Police I retired
in 2019. I'm currently a member of the
New Hampshire Troopers Association in
the New Hampshire Police Association and
both entities are opposed to this bill
I'm going to be very brief because I
believe my colleague officer Daley spoke
about most of the concerns we have
you know obviously one of the concerns
we have is this takes away some local
control from the municipalities as State
Police doesn't affect us as much we're
usually out on the highways and some of
the larger roadways but there are times
where you know if they can't fill a
detail at a local town they sometimes
will either call the sheriff's
department or the state police to see if
one of us could fill in that role so
look this does take away some local
control
two uh I think Public Safety is
important uh I can tell you there's been
numerous occasions where Troopers have
been working details uh and have
received uh they call them bolos be on
the lookout for and it could be anything
from an armed robbery a theft even up to
a homicide
um any number of things DWIs erratic
operations whatever it might be
a lot of times these uh Troopers that
are on these details can take that
enforcement or action or look out for
that vehicle while they're there during
the traffic uh uh assignment uh I think
representative you asked you know does
that take away from the crew that's on
the side of the road I would say that
most of the occasions the enforcement
action is taken right there at the scene
so they're still there with the crew uh
what would happen is another a trooper
would call an on-duty Trooper to come
and then handle the rest of the
situation at that point but they would
be the ones that could make that
immediate uh detention
so Public Safety this this does affect
Public Safety
and lastly you've heard a lot about
Recruitment and Retention I can tell you
we do have a recruitment and retention
specifically State Police is down 70
Troopers which is about 20 percent of
our state police force uh that we're
trying to struggle to recruit and retain
the ones that we have
I can tell you uh from my career when I
first started as a young police officer
young trooper I did a lot of these
construction details I worked with a lot
of these construction companies as I got
older and as I progressed through the uh
the uh the years on the job uh
financially I no longer needed it so I
didn't do it as much but I can tell you
that for young police officers that are
starting young families uh this is you
know extra Financial money that assists
them in getting off the ground uh I can
tell you my wife and I struggled when I
was a young police officer and so this
would only hurt that Recruitment and
Retention make it worse I wanted to keep
it very brief but with that I'm willing
to take any questions that you may have
and thank you for allowing me to speak
today
three minutes and eight seconds very
good
representative Gallagher
um so about the recruitment and
um retention
part
um
couldn't this also
possibly reduce the number of
slots that need to be recruited for in
I'm not quite sure I understand the
question but I'm assuming the question
has to do with our you mean taking away
from these available officers to be out
there on the street already is that what
you're asking about
or
um
representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um do you have
um concerns that
um
uh about overwork of our police officers
um and that they're that they need some
decompression time to be able to uh
effectively you know do their job when
they are on duty and how
um and if these types of opportunities
may put them in that continued stressful
environment where they don't have that
time to decompress sure so
um police officers obviously have a
schedule some people have Monday through
Friday schedules like I had towards the
end of my career when I worked in major
crime most Patrol uh Troopers or Patrol
officers use a rotating schedule so they
have different days off during the week
and that's usually when they will pick
up these details or on the days off or
after hours so to speak I know State
Police and I'm pretty sure a lot of the
Departments too have a policy that
speaks specifically to working extra
construction or extra Duty details and
State Police specifically limits the
amount of hours that you can work
those for that specific reason because
they want their law enforcement to have
thank you very much representative L
Word
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
does the municipality or the city
contract directly with the officer
contract with the officer individually
no so what occurs is they contract with
the the department uh whatever
Department that's going to hire them so
for example if you had a small town and
none of their officers were available to
do this they would contact the company
itself would contact either the
sheriff's department or the Troopers uh
you know the state police and would say
I need one police officer for this job
at this location
that agency would then take that
information send it out to their
available offices and say hey anybody
interested in work in this detail
somebody would raise their hand say yes
I do what would happen is that agency
would Bill the contractor the contractor
would pay the bill and then that the
agency basically pays up front the
officer that goes there so they're
recouping the cost on the back end from
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I I'm also a
selectman in my town and is it it's my
understanding that uh this issue is
usually coming under a Union contract
and do you know of any other communities
in the state that have this issue
covered
in my when I say the issue I mean who
goes first you know I have a list uh and
uh what how much we charge how much
money comes back to the town and it's a
discretionary fund that's used for the
police officers to buy bullets and that
kind of thing is that did you have any
issue like that I can't speak to what
every agency does uh I can speak to my
knowledge of what state police does so
there is some language in our uh collect
a bargaining agreement that speaks to
details and specifically there is rules
as to uh who can be next on the list
when a detail comes forward so with the
state police they go by who has the
fewest number of hours and they fill
those people first before they go to the
people that have more hours on record
already
they do build a company a certain flat
fee and that Fleet flat fee incorporates
the police officers uh pay uh portion of
the benefits and with State Police you
get a cruiser so there's a there's a
it's a little bit higher sometimes in a
local agency because you're also paying
for the cruiser so now
um a lot of times the agency does
sometimes have a few extra dollars left
over here and there but it's usually not
a cash cow so to speak
um and sometimes if that builds up a
little bit they may use it to build to
um uh buy some funds that sometimes
relate to this like for example I
remember State Police one time I took
the excess funds that they had in this
account and they bought new high
visibility uh rain jackets for the
Troopers to use on these details
follow-up Mr chairman follow-up yeah I I
know that your
knowledge is on a state level well I was
more than interested in local levelists
but did you do you know that in many
cases if not all cases when there is a
Union contract between the local
community that this issue is in that
contract and is part of that contract
and is controlled by that contract and
it's a note negotiated item between the
police officers and the town I can speak
to one other town and the reason I can
do that is because uh I'm I'm after I
retired I became an attorney so I'm
legal counsel for the Salem Police
employees Association so to use them as
an example uh Salem Salem does have it
in the contract and Salem does
specifically state in the contract what
the rate of pay for the actual police
officers will be in the contract now
what the town of Salem charges above and
beyond that to cover its costs I'm not
entirely sure all right thank you thank
you okay so you know other questions uh
thank you for your testimony next we
I'm going to try and fit in this chair
here
hi my name is Michael Donahue
I am currently a sergeant in the traffic
unit for the Manchester Police
Department
I'm here in opposition to this bill and
I'd like to give a quick testimony to
the same
I've been in law enforcement for 19 and
a half years prior to working Manchester
I worked for the town of Amherst New
Hampshire
and being in the traffic in Manchester
my job is to handle motor vehicle
complaints major crashes fatal crashes
and develop different traffic plans for
the school district and so on addition
and additionally to my current position
I organize all of the City events in
Manchester that take up a public way
so that encompasses over 100 events a
year to include road races parades
marathons and so on
all of these events take numerous police
officers given the safety concerns of of
the people involved in the events
it's my opinion that this bill is
intended to save money as as was
testified earlier in that the savings
would be passed on what the bill doesn't
address is that um
foreign
doesn't address and that we're not
thinking all the way through is that the
understanding of how these police
details take mind of traffic enforcement
on each event as they're there so they
have to move barricades they have to
override traffic lights and they're
required to stop people when necessary
sometimes people don't look at the cones
they don't look at the manual changes or
physical changes you've made to the
scene
with over 100 events annually just
through the special events process never
mind the everyday details as officer
daily testified earlier we have 22 today
and there are no special events today
that require the public worldwide
um
the language in this bill allows for
someone like me to justify the existence
of a police server each time but the
words in it shall and only are extremely
powerful and leave every scenario up for
an explanation from me in order to
follow
the need for law enforcement at the
smaller details is in order to prevent
accidents keep the motoring public safe
whether it be through the temporary
physical change lane changes and so on
stoppage of Lights further right-of-way
or the manual movement of traffic with
someone's arms the key is when drivers
don't obey these issues what happens
then with the presence of law
enforcement through lights through their
through their uniforms it strongly
deters that behavior in the first place
but they're allowed to take enforcement
action when necessary
um an additional thing I'd like to
address is the Recruitment and Retention
I don't want to use that term over and
over again because you have but it
specifically relates to the retirement
the retirement bills that changes in
2012 had a drastic effect on how they
get paid out in pension and that's why
the recruitment retention is the
conversation that we keep repeating
the issue for using police details is
for a police officer to earn extra extra
money the retirement as it's called
Changed completely and so that officers
now have to have a separate set of
investments in order to do in order to
retire retirement doesn't mean what it
meant back in 2012 so now if an officer
is prohibited from making extra pay
after their 40 hours which is usually
what a detail will do for the police
officer at the benefit of the City by
having them there
they people will not stay on this job
for a length of time if you prohibit
them from making a livable wage in
retirement at the end and that's why the
recruitment retention is the argument
that keeps coming up and I just want
everybody to understand that it's the
questions have been asked this is
something that is voluntarily signed up
for 90 of the time that officers take in
addition to their 40 hours I deal with
this on a regular basis it is my
full-time job to organize these events
and police officers are required for
most of what we're dealing with here in
the word shall and only in this prohibit
me from doing the job correctly
thank you
representative Kellum
um
I I guess I didn't really understand
your full introduction are you on duty
and are you representing
um a specific department or yourself I'm
I'm here on my own accord I gave you my
professional accolades as I'm here
because I stepped away from the job to
further questions
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so um I'm starting to
understand the the repeat question that
I ask of witnesses
um pertaining to specific safety
concerns about a project so projects are
not is it true that projects are not sim
exclusively construction projects it
could be a marathon it could be I don't
know some type of an event
correct there the the range would be
enormous
follow-up Mr chair
follow-up regardless of the nature of
when you when you have a detail who is
it that goes in
within the municipality and for example
sets up detours sets up the cones
overrides traffic lights Etc is that
always the police department or does
that if there's a project that's going
to utilize flaggers did they set up an
override those types of um Traffic
Control Systems if you will okay so the
physical
tools that we use columns traffic cone
signs and so forth if a police officer
there is per is provided by the city
using an example is the amount of road
races and parades that Manchester has we
use them frequently the private
companies who contract through the city
to do it through our special events will
provide cones to their own level however
all of the setup and takedown is done at
the discretion of the police department
in this situation my position as a
traffic Sergeant I have to make sure
that the cones are set up a certain way
to give certain birth to cars the
certain width to stop different things
so we provide that I don't understand
fully what the flaggers would provide
other than the person but I don't know
that answer
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so
taking off a little bit on
representative Powers question
given what you just said
does the language in the bill
in your view prevent
local Municipal officials from
adequately addressing safety concerns
before they become safety concerns
because of the words shall and only yes
see no more hands thank you very much
thank you chairman uh for the committee
and thank the committee my name is Gary
Abbott I'm the Executive Vice President
of the associated general contractors of
New Hampshire
uh I wanted to clarify a couple of
things at first I didn't know if I was
going to speak or not because I looked
at this bill and I'm trying to figure
out exactly what it does now let's just
have it before we go on uh on your pink
card you didn't put for a pose or
anything I did not because I'm going to
talk about the language of the bill that
makes it confusing and why I don't
really have a position at this point
um
currently there is I represent
contractors who use flaggers as well as
police and as well as State Police and I
want the committee to know there's an
appropriate time for each of those to
control traffic
it is not a one or another it is based
on circumstances of what the road and
what you're doing uh and that would
require the safety concerns
I think with this bill and what the past
study that you have was trying to
address is situations in which
an ordinance is made that mandates one
way
and doesn't look at the total project or
the safety concerns and what's necessary
and I think that's what the Bill's
trying to do but it has it opens up
safety concerns which means the town's
still going to decide whether who does
the detail or who does traffic control
the other word that's uh uh is difficult
for me is temporary traffic control I'm
not sure I know the definition of
temporary traffic control there are
different conditions where somebody's
working on a utility pole that might be
there for an hour or two and then there
are people in the commercial business
that I represent that'll be Paving a
road all day long for eight hours a day
that has either flaggers or police to
control that so I think that's what the
bill is trying to do is make it so it's
in the statute that you can't pick one
over the other each has its own place so
I wanted to bring that forward to the
committee I'm not so sure the language
fixes all of that but I know that's what
I think the study
I know the committee keeps asking about
what is safety concerns well clearly
you've been through Paving projects at
Paving roads that's not a high volume
flaggers are doing the detail it's
appropriate in those cases flag is would
be appropriate on dead end roads for
utility work flaggers would be
appropriate where we don't see the major
safety concern that it requires a police
detail
and there's the manual on uniform
traffic control that's put out by the
federal government that a lot of
construction follows
and it gives guidelines also dot has
guidelines which when things are
appropriate for different projects so
I'm bringing that up also was talked
about training our association does the
training for flag training so I want to
dispel any rumors that like they're not
qualified there are requirements for
State projects many municipalities
follow those State projects for their
local highways and improvements so we
train those flat we train trainers to be
within companies there are companies
that do flag training so I don't want
you to think that's just somebody out of
the blue or the major corporations of
Highway contracts have their own flag
Crews so that can be take place so I
want to just clarify all of those things
so you don't misinterpret this bill that
I think it's trying to address because
any time that you
we agree safety should come first over
all of the other things that you've
listened to but there are times that
it's this the flagger is appropriate and
so therefore I just want to bring that
to the committee I know I may have been
close to my three minutes even though I
wrote five before I got that instruction
but uh I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
Mr Abbott no you were over your time
limit but that's okay
um do we have any questions for Mr
Abbott uh representative thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
you clarified a lot of things but as I
see it from your testimony it says
current what's existing currently
addresses a lot of issues uh in terms of
who to use when to use at the local
level am I correct in understanding that
you're you're correct to a point but I
will tell you there are disputes over
the years of a flagging company is
trying to do a job and the local
municipality comes in and says you
cannot do that I've received those phone
calls regarding what Authority so we're
into the legal authority of who has
legal control so I'm not saying there
isn't those disputes currently that
happen
representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question so the sense that I got from
your testimony was that the um that
there is some guidelines especially uh
Federal and
um maybe the local municipality is not
utilizing those guidelines and is over
regulating because possibly because they
are trying to incentivize or be able to
pay their officers more money and they
don't they want to be able to offer this
option to them to get more money and so
there's some some kind of incentive for
them to not follow the more standard
practice of the federal government is
that kind of the issue that is I guess I
guess what I want to clarify is I think
what happens is and I know you're the
municipal and County government
committee but I think at times
municipalities don't see the whole
picture they don't they don't recognize
that there should be I would like to see
municipalities adopt a guideline like
what dot puts out or some guideline
what's the appropriate use and when and
get away from uh the whole compensation
thing I think that's where I come from
is that safety should be it use the
guidelines that are currently that
either dot follows or the manual for
uniform traffic control that does that's
what I would recommend and I think the
problem is is that many municipalities
when they write these ordinances they
don't write that piece I hope that
answers your question
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um and it may have already been answered
I'm not sure do qualify or your
organization does training and Dot has
guidelines is so two-part question is
there one standard or certification that
all flaggers have and then
do those flaggers need to have all used
continuing education you know to to keep
up with standards well I I can tell you
that uh
the dot writes their their standard into
the contracts into the specifications of
what you take and therefore come the
requirements so almost all the
organizations that teach flagging I'm
not the only organization that teaches
flag there's certain criteria and they
have to go through this flagging at
least every four years
so there are components to this and
there are certain things that we as an
association we teach this have to cover
and trust me dot officials Federal
Highway have attended my classes I've
had police attend our classes so we've
gone through the review and that kind of
thing there are also National
organizations that just deal with
traffic and safety and they put on
courses as well locally and online so
you can have courses but there is
criteria it's not completely the wild
west it there are some standards that
are put in place
uh representative state
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you think that the
bill as written covers all of the
eventualities that you just clarified
for us I I don't I I think there's some
gaps in what I think I understand I
think what the verbiage it's very brief
and uh you know I'd love to see that you
know all of the factors taken into place
if they're going to do a local ordinance
but I'm not so sure this does it but I
think this does try to prevent an
ordinance from saying you can only do
one way
thank you
representative priests
yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um are there any mandates that temporary
flaggers have to take your training and
yes
in the sense that
we teach the situations in which it's
mandatory like working for a D.O.T
project and we go over what those
specifications are or if the town adopts
those kind of specifications in say road
building a lot of times they adopt all
of the standards that are in the the dot
those would apply so it's it's
it's training in which it's anybody who
is going to be probably a flagging
company is going to make sure they've
trained their people in accordance with
either a national standard or by the
local regs
seeing no more questions
representative McDonald
I thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question for you sir
you're a construction worker and you're
out on 95 and you're raking asphalt
you want a trooper or police officer
blue light or do you want a guy holding
a sign that says slow down
it depends on the situation and it
depends on the type of projects I mean
we work with the state police a lot
because on uh highways we don't want
flaggers so there are different
scenarios in which the contractor will
say Gary we absolutely don't want
flaggers in those situations
but I what I'm trying to cast here is
which would you rather have
excuse me Mr chairman well
never mind sir
thank you
see no more questions I have one brief
one um my understanding of what you're
saying is that there's not a
one-size-fits all to win a flagger or an
officer should be used that's my
understanding of what you're saying
you're also stipulating that the current
language does not quite capture that
sentiment is it do you think that you
would be able to draft is is it possible
to draft language that would actually
um
I'm not so sure I could do it in the
time frame of that you were set in to to
come up with because there was a whole
study committee looked at it and uh
I'm not so sure I could do that
seeing no more questions
uh thank you for your testimony thank
you and last pink card uh nature Grace
foreign
thank you Mr chair nature craze for the
municipal Association I do oppose this
bill I can't speak to what my
predecessor might have thought in 2015
but to go directly to representative
power's question
um there is vague language in this in
this bill I do not know the meaning of
the term specific safety concerns and
certainly the question of who would
determine that and what would the appeal
process be is something that I would
raise as a question as well
to get to the chairs question
um I uh I
do not know whether it would be possible
to draft language that would address
this particular issue because as Mr
Abbott said
um there are certainly circumstances
where a non-uniformed officer is more
appropriate and
where a uniformed officer is more
appropriate so civilian or a uniformed
officer
and that's going to be determined on the
bait on the basis of
the specific facts and circumstances so
for example uh
most municipalities this point in time
use uniformed officers for Traffic
Control in road races and marathons
prior to what happened in Boston a few a
few years ago they did not do so because
they were not aware there might be
safety concerns related to that flaggers
were more common
although certainly uniformed officers
were present at various times
I do want to point out a couple other
things for the committee as well
um representative McDonald asked a
question about uh construction on 93 and
on federal highways there actually is a
specific Federal Highway administrative
630.1106 C which requires use of
uniformed officers on Federal Highway
projects I believe that has to do with
funding of those projects
um it's been referenced several times
the New Hampshire dot has a flagger and
uniformed officer use in work zones
guidelines there's also the federal
Manual of traffic control devices that
Federal Manual of traffic control
devices is required to be used by
municipalities uh as far as the flagger
versus uh uniformed officer comes in
that's really decision based on local
conditions and so really the the point
is that the locals are going to know
what the specific public safety concerns
are in that particular Road stretch of
highway wherever they are as well as any
other
factors that may weigh in there and they
would be the most appropriate ones to
determine what is appropriate in that
particular circumstance that's all I
have Mr chair
[Music]
representative yokella thank you thank
you for taking the question so when the
state puts out these guidelines for when
to use flaggers and when to use officers
it is it am I understanding your
testimony correctly that no in fact the
local con the local municipality has
more expertise to know when that is when
they're uh the flaggers versus uniform
officers is more appropriate and shows
should have the power to override what
the FED what the state has has uh deemed
the guidelines for this
so the state has guidelines they use in
state projects and most municipalities
also follow those because they help
determine when a flagger versus
uniformed officer is appropriate
um but
who the ultimately it's the at the
moment it is the local municipality that
decides uh what is appropriate in that
particular circumstance
thank you
representative Gallagher
um so
I have a question about the fiscal note
since it says you were contacted for
that
um
so
the the part about potentially
decreasing costs I understand that makes
sense but the sentence before that when
it says
um
uh talks about this may alter the
revenue accrued from special detail
projects could you go more into how that
works short I'm happy to provide the
full fiscal note form that I filled out
for for
uh
my brain skipping here but
um or less oh uh yeah
and um but the long and the short is
depending on exactly how this language
is interpreted it may be the case that
uniformed officers are used less
frequency frequently or perhaps more
frequently depending on what exactly the
term uh specific safety concerns means
and that would result typically what
happens is officers have municipalities
set up a special detail fund and that's
authorized under a different statute and
then operates to pay for the cost of
having an officer out there all the
maintenance for the vehicles Etc
um and so that would be uh that fund is
held separately it's not part of usual
Appropriations it's very specific in
what it can be used for that's basically
the officer's pay retirement Etc while
they're on details and typically the
municipality pays a or charges a set
cost for that and it may depend on
whether there's a vehicle or not so
depending on how this is interpreted
that may mean officers are used more in
which case they would have more Revenue
into that fund if it's interpreted that
they are used less then they may have
less Revenue I couldn't determine that
at the time based on the language of the
see representative management
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Greece
for taking my question
can the municipality uh at this time as
the law exists or the
um can they deny a construction or a
project if they use flaggers versus the
police officer at this time does the
local municipality have the authority to
do that with the safety and concern so
they wouldn't deny approval of the
project but as the project occurs it may
be the case that you know someone
notifies the police department hey there
are people out there directing traffic
and it's not a police officer it may be
the case that then you know the the
police chief and the select board or
tenant administrator has a a
conversation with that construction
company and typically they work that out
ahead of time about who will be there to
direct traffic because that's really the
question
foreign
no more questions thank you for your
testimony thank you I have no more pink
cards on the blue sheet I have five
people who signed in three opposed and
two no preference
okay thank you
sorry 526 that was closing on 526 and
now we will open up the hearing on eight
HB
you're going to introduce
the the private sponsor had to go to an
executive session could we just wait
until after lunch to
move on we can't she has exact sessions
all day she contacted me prior and I
specifically asked her to have uh one of
the other Representatives come fine I'm
so we'll go ahead and open up uh 467
relative to public playground
accessibility
go ahead
Mr chair members of the committee I'm
here today to introduce House Bill 467
relative to public playground
accessibility
thank you for that introductions we have
three pink cards we will start with uh
hello my name is Chase eagleson I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Council
on developmental disabilities we are
here in support of the bill
uh we believe he'll have a really great
positive impact for the spirit community
and uh
uh for two reasons one it gives the
ability for parents caregivers and
Guardians with mobility issues
to more easily care for and get access
to the children they're caring for
and number two
it's
important for children at a young age to
socialize and play
and this allows for children with
mobility issues to be able to get to
playground equipment to be able to
utilize it be able to have fun and play
with their friends
and we believe that this will have a
great impact on the early childhood
development of these children
uh representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question would you be open in the bill
if it was written that
basically
as long as people connect
access the play structures or whatever
then that's fine it doesn't need to be
specified what type of material
anything that increased successfully
before I know that this was chosen
because most playgrounds have mulch
which you cannot uh use a wheelchair on
and it's very hard to get even grounding
on so anything that would make it easier
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh and I and you as I
uh read this bill if you have a
playground and uh ought to
fulfill the requirements
you'd almost have to cover the whole
surface
you it the whole surface of the
playground you you couldn't have uh
uh Pathways going from one to the other
not knowing which one you pick first or
second or third it seemed to me that
this would require that you'd cover the
whole surface of the playground is that
I it probably makes more sense to go to
representative Catawba on that but I
believe that is the uh intense uh so
that children with mobility issues
parents Guardians caregivers mobility
issues to be able to access their
children and to play at any point on the
playground yes
follow-up
if that is the case then don't you have
to put in the bill the size of the
playground
otherwise
I'm concerned that if this went forward
that would be a deterrent to people
putting in playgrounds because it would
cost so much to be it would be uh
unintended consequence because people
would just not put the playgrounds in
because they couldn't follow the rules
would you be interested in changing the
the bill so that it would at least
identify the size of the playgrounds uh
I have no preference on I'm not sure the
council has preference on it uh
I'm not I don't believe the size of a
playground is really something that we
were identifying here more of just the
accessibility of the surface
I don't know if that answers your
question at all
all right thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh is there a
condition
um under which this is required by uh
federal law the Ada law and and towns
must comply when they're renovating as
opposed to building new I'm not sure uh
I mean I know the Ada law would would
back this but I am not 100 sure if
there's a current legislation on that no
representative treble
thank you Mr chair and thanks very much
for taking my question thanks for coming
this is a lot of testimony so I'll have
great reading uh I wonder if any
research we've had bills before us in
the past about artificial turf on
athletic fields and I heard some very
disturbing research in regards to the
toxicity because it's chopped up tires
or other kinds of rubber in with that do
you have any information or comments
about the kind of rubber that might be
used in this bill
I don't uh as someone who doesn't know
much about toxicity of certain uh no
problem materials I don't know much
about it I know in the bill it also
States you could use a rubber composite
of some sort yes
um I'm not sure which would be safer but
would be open to anything that's
increased accessibility for it thanks
thanks representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much for taking my question and I
apologize in advance if it's something
you can't answer but as I read the
current requirements of the Americans
with Disabilities Act this is already
required effectively
it's required fairly in all playgrounds
then this would just uh allow for a push
it to be done in playgrounds throughout
the state
it's required federally it's already
required
I don't know much about the federal
requirements of uh rubber compositor
composite for surfacing for uh
playgrounds federally so I do have a
question for you and my question is is
that a follow-up representative yes it's
a problem Mr chair thank you so much
um
do you have experience with playgrounds
outside of New Hampshire have you you
know do you have you seen play at
grounds that you do consider accessible
and
if you could just give us a general
description of how they differ from the
kinds of playgrounds that this bill
seems to be addressing
yeah of course so uh I actually worked
at one point at the tuck Youth Camp in
Hampton New Hampshire and a lot of times
we would go to playgrounds where there
was mulch surfacing
uh which people in wheelchairs are
unable to get over
uh but there are playgrounds throughout
this state but not all playgrounds
obviously uh that have more of a smooth
surfacing
that would that allows for uh people
mobility issues and people in
wheelchairs to be able to get across
them
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
in a nutshell what you're asking for is
an inclusionary playground where any
individual with any level of
disabilities can participate socially
yes we believe that inclusion at a young
age and learning inclusion of people
with different abilities would greatly
Aid in the feeling of inclusion as they
age
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
do you believe that
is it your opinion that the playground
could have a
surface for accessibility but not have a
complete port in place surface that
covers the entire area
just trying to which it which is
permitted through the Ada
and do you believe that that's okay
we would prefer that all areas were
accessible to uh people with mobility
issues and different abilities uh but I
could get back to you on that and what
the council believes thank you
see no more quite representative priest
could we wait I see the prime sponsors
here and I know she has issues so with
scheduling
actually this is a question for the
disability okay go ahead
thank you Mr chairman for taking this
quick question and thank you for taking
my question
with people with disabilities
is there a difference between the
surface materials concrete asphalt
rubberized surfaces as to how they give
if there is an accident and the patient
falls or the visitor Falls onto their
ground
I don't have much knowledge on the
physics of uh injuries when someone
Falls onto a surface I'm sure that
cement is much harder and rubber has a
little bit more give uh when some if
someone were to fall onto it but I can
try to get back to you on that if
possible
okay thank you for your testimony uh
representative
foreign
scheduling issues I had exact session so
House Bill 467
seeks to make new playgrounds accessible
only on the pathways to get to the
equipment and I do want to clarify that
this is a federal law and it has been
for the last 11 years
however
the federal law points to an ASTM
standard which defines that in order for
the path to be considered handicap
accessible
you have to exert more no more than
seven percent more Force as you would if
you were on a flat surface and so
Danny of you know how to measure that
because I certainly don't it doesn't
give an actual answer for which
piece of material that you need to
accomplish that and so towns are
building
what they think will work they're
getting quotes and then it turns out
that it's not handicap accessible and
then they're required to fix it because
they didn't meet the federal law so in
my town in Windham we're doing that at
two of our different playgrounds and our
elementary school is estimated to be
fixed at a cost of a half million
dollars and it was just built a few
years ago if we had gotten it right the
first time we wouldn't be having to do
that and those kids would have been able
to use the playground
I do want to mention that the analysis
although it says that it's for
playgrounds in use on or after that's
incorrect it is only for for playgrounds
that are constructed after the date
and I did speak to OLS about it they
said that it doesn't affect the the bill
at all that's just their blurb the
person who wrote it has since retired
they didn't think that it it doesn't
affect the actual bill itself so there
was no reason for me to make an
amendment to to clarify that
um the bill does allow for
other
um
similar surface material that's not
loose fell so I know there was a
question about cheaper materials that's
certainly allowed I know that rap
priests had a question about fall
attenuation and that is covered by some
of the standards so in a fall zone where
you might be falling off of a swing or a
slide or something like that there are
requirements that it has to have a
certain
attenuation to the child is not going to
get hurt and so what I'm really looking
to do is to basically clarify
so that we can understand what's the
intent behind the federal law so that we
don't keep making mistakes and having
kids that can't use the playground and B
having to pay to fix that afterwards
I think it's kind of you know when we're
asking the town a lot of towns will put
on a warrant article you know the cost
to build a playground and the voters
vote for it and then they come back
afterwards and they say well now we're
legally obligated under federal law to
fix it because we we messed up and we
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question is
um when a municipality decides to
install a playground
who does the design of the playground
and is there someone designing this
playground to be
compliant with this the federal law
that's been referenced
they a lot of times will get different
quotes and the thing is is that while
you may have a material that when it's
first put on will pass the standard and
it's cheaper so they're putting that out
there because it's a cheaper bed they
want to get the bid on the playground
in New England as you know we have you
know lots of unpredictable weather and
so unless you have maintenance staff to
literally break it flat every single day
um like the engineering wood fiber for
example
you can't it doesn't meet this
requirement and so most people don't
have enough
staff in their towns to literally have
it flattened out that and it also that
breaks down quite a bit because of our
New England weather it disintegrates
um and so yes they they do have people
putting it out there
um in terms of quotes but I don't think
they're certainly not pointing out to
the town like hey by the way if you
choose this option you're going to have
to keep breaking it like at our
elementary school if they wanted to use
like the engineering wood fiber for
example they would literally have to
rake it after every recess because it
uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks
representative it's nice to see you and
hear you explain
um although the gentleman before you did
well I'm wondering if you all thought
about considering speaking to a physical
therapist or someone who works with
folks who use adaptive materials to hone
in on this seven percent more accessible
power use I know that ski areas have
adaptive skiing and they may be able to
answer that kind of a question I wonder
if you considered that
so I I did speak with several in the
disability community and it's not that
you can't make somebody else adapt their
device to meet that your playground has
to meet that criteria and so I suggested
materials that do meet that criteria but
then I did also say or a similar solid
surf material surface material so if
there's something better like I know the
town of Exeter came out and told me that
they were using these mats which were
pretty cheap that were interlock mats
they put them up on their on their
playground and they were able to fix it
in that way so there certainly are many
alternatives to this available that can
be economical thank you
representative Guthrie next
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
my biggest concern would you believe
that my biggest concern about this that
we may have regulated ourselves to the
point we're going to have an unintended
consequence and not build playgrounds
so no because I believe right now we
have the unintended consequence that
we're having to fix the playgrounds that
we do build because they don't meet the
requirements and so then taxpayers are
forced to then fund to fix it and so I
think we already have the unintended
consequence and I think we need to keep
in mind that it's it's also not even
just children it can be caretakers of
children that are trying to take their
kids out to the playground and they may
have a wheelchair themselves or a walker
and they also can't navigate in these
environments so it's not even just the
kids but it's just you know a complete
inaccessibility issue and so I think
with the amount of times that it's being
raised I think we already have an
unintended consequence that
towns are voting these playgrounds in
and then the taxpayers are paying to fix
them
based on that then uh
if we already have the unintended
consequence this does not solve it just
just identifies it and makes it to a
point where now everybody knows what the
rules are and the rules are so regulated
do you believe that we can that as the
I'm unintended kind of consequences
classic words of let's not build any
more playgrounds because they're too
expensive and we want to have only
playgrounds that are very limited in
size and so in uh builds just separate
for those people who are handicapped no
I don't believe so because the town of
Concord is upgrading their playground
right now to be accessible on the town
of Exeter just upgraded upgraded theirs
there are certain requirements for
schools for example to have outdoor play
areas for the kids and so I don't think
that schools just aren't going to have
playgrounds as a result so I don't know
I don't believe that will happen and I
believe that there are many
cost-effective options and this doesn't
seek to make the entire playground
handicap accessible this this states
that there needs to be Pathways
um from the entry into the pieces of the
playground equipment but you may have
you know a huge area of playground but
you're not required to make each piece
this material it's just that the piece
is leading up the child needs to have a
pathway representative thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I'm
still trying to wrap my head around how
this dovetails with the Ada
and in the language of the bill
in line five it says in addition to
meeting general safety standards in Ada
standards
so
are the things that you're outlining in
this bill on top of what the Ada already
requires and if that's the case then
what specifically are those things that
the Ada doesn't require but this bill
proposes to require
so the Ada requires that you have to
have the accessible Pathways it just
doesn't Define what that material that
that pathway has to be made out of and
in different areas of the country
different things may work in our area of
the country it's basically been shown
this is the solution to make it work
this is what our municipalities and what
our schools are up updating their
playgrounds to be
that's very helpful representative
Cahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
I I have a good friend who became a
paraplegic who was a skateboarder
he still skateboards he has a special
wheelchair
I kind of want to know does playground
include skate parks stuff like that
because that has to be a
hard material
no because it's specifying playground
specifically so no it would it's just a
public playground and so this also
doesn't apply to private playground
areas in terms of if your development
has a homeowners association that has
built their own private playground this
wouldn't apply to that this applies only
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
a lot of towns have impact fees for
development that go into a recreation
revolving fund as well as
um
just Parks and Rec funds that
fees go into to do just this kind of
thing is that something you've commonly
seen that it doesn't take the taxpayers
money it takes the who is using the
place to fund new new projects like this
so in my looking it's typically a warned
article on the ballot and they'll
usually specify where the funds may or
may not be coming from so yes they
certainly could use those funds to apply
to this if that's what they had them
representative thank you I was wondering
if I was blacklisted Mr chair thank you
for giving me an opportunity yeah
um
thank you for taking my question
by increasing the safety of the
playground whether it is for people with
disability or adaptive equipment
that also increases the safety for
everybody that's using the playground
yes that is correct so it was also
brought to my attention that several
preschools even with kids that are
typical kids
frequently have Falls tripping on other
types of materials that
wouldn't happen nearly as regularly as
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
I'd like to know our playgrounds
not to my knowledge not not against the
the
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm curious about the the timing and
the dates the question is my thought is
why not make it effective immediately
and I ask that maybe this maybe this
wouldn't happen but uh so many towns
across the state have set their budgets
and they would go into effect after the
fiscal year starts on July 1st they may
be prepared only for what they have
budgeted for which would not comply here
but would still be compliant if they did
it in this fiscal in this calendar year
so I'm curious why not make it effective
immediately was there any thought to
that
so this says that constructed for use on
or after January 1st 2024 the reason
that I had put that out there was to
give towns who maybe already had
something
going in although it's not compliant and
they should probably switch up their
plans
um that it wouldn't mandate that they
had to although yes like you suggested
it would certainly behoove them to
follow it the right way because they're
only just going to end up having to fix
it I'd be
you know certainly in in support of of
modifying the date if you feel that
that's
seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you I
appreciate it call uh Jennifer Bertrand
good afternoon my name is Jennifer
Bertrand
um I live in Mount Vernon New Hampshire
I appreciate uh
the house Municipal and County
government committee and chairman
turcott
um
to hear my testimony today I am a mother
of four children and my younger now
adult daughter Chloe experiences a
disability and when she was in Middle
School she ended up needing a very
involved orthopedic surgery where she
had to have her heel cords lengthened
and her tendons transferred and for more
than eight weeks she was in a long leg
cast and had to use a wheelchair
and it was very difficult because during
that time and it was only you know a
little over eight weeks that she
had to use the wheelchair to be mobile
and get around
there were no local playgrounds where we
lived that would allow her access and
opportunity at a time where she really
needed to get outside and be around kids
and it really would have helped to
um
past that time that she went through
this recovery process more quickly we'd
have to drive down to South Nashua there
was a playground off of exit one near
the sky metal Meadow Country Club and it
had a design just like is outlined in
this legislation where from the entrance
around the perimeter of the playground
into each piece of equipment there was a
hard surface let me tell you it was very
handy no pun intended or maybe pun
intended for me having one hand and
pushing her in the wheelchair to have
that surface Not only was it important
to her because it provided her a pathway
to be able to access the playground with
kids with and without disabilities but
it also allowed me to be able to take
her there and for her to enjoy that
experience Chloe experiences an
intellectual and developmental
disability she loves swinging even today
she's an adult
and those opportunities to socialize
with kids in the playground it helped
her to build her communication skills
her fine and gross motor skills her
coordination skills learn problem
solving skills it's so important that we
take a universal approach
when we're designing public spaces
shouldn't tax paying Citizens homeowners
that pay property taxes be able to
access the public spaces in their
communities
that's sort of like the feel-good side
of this right but there's also a very
important cost
consideration I know that representative
Guthrie had expressed some concerns well
if we pass this legislation we'll you
know towns be reluctant to build
playgrounds well it will that will this
passing this bill make it more expensive
on the back of my testimony I don't know
if you've noticed but
I included some information about
engineered wood fiber which is actually
used at the Mont Vernon Village School
playground right now if Chloe were still
in a wheelchair she wouldn't be able to
access the equipment or the swings or
for other students who use wheelchairs
they wouldn't be able to access it or
veterans grandparents other adults that
might experience disabilities it's not
an exclusive Club any one of us could
have an injury and an illness that
require us to have an assistive device
or
you know need to use a wheelchair
the engineered wood fiber
is very costly the um
dust that is emitted from the material
can also be problem some to allergy
sufferers and I like the way that the
representatives outline this bill
leaving it sufficiently open to use an
alternative material so this bill really
provides guidance to help towns to make
cost-effective decisions
and it also gives towns the flexibility
and choice to choose materials that are
most appropriate for their communities
so I ask you to support HB 467 and let's
work together to make our communities
accessible to everyone
questions
thank you for your testimony
representative man chaputi
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'll ask you again thank you
that's my constituents and that's my
ward which you're talking Roby Park and
I'm very glad that we have that and my
question is again this will bring an
inclusionary public space for any
ability any
skill level
quote
I'm sorry
both for the children as well as the
caregivers or the accompanying adult
correct it makes inclusionary for all
yeah it's a Universal Design no matter
what your abilities are and if you're a
mother who also has other children in a
baby stroller and you're trying to
follow maybe your older child around and
you have an infant that's napping in the
stroller it certainly makes it more easy
for moms or dads who bring their
children to the playground or
grandparents who are you know caring and
providing some child care for working
parents
it's a win-win for everyone and it's
more cost effective I think sometimes
when towns make the decision to use
something like engineered wood fiber
like Mont Vernon did and other towns
have done they don't realize the
maintenance costs and the fact that
unless it is raked out you know in some
cases on a daily basis it's not
accessible and they could face legal
repercussions that could be far more
costly down the road so let's take an
informed approach and this legislation
will enable us to do that thank you you
answered the question a while ago thank
you okay
uh further questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony uh final speaker
thank you Mr chair and each crease for
the municipal Association we are in
favor of this bill
um as as already stated uh this is
already federal law and I just want to
point you to uh the Ada standards for
accessible design adopted in 2010 there
are three requirements for playgrounds
they have to have an accessible path
from the building or parking lot to the
edge of the play area they have to have
an accessible path from the edge of the
play area to the playground equipment
and surfaces have to comply with atsm
1951 which is the surface systems for
under and around playground equipment
and I want to thank representative kutab
for doing an incredible amount of
research on this
um because as it happens not all of the
surfacing materials contained within
that atsm are actually appropriate for
New Hampshire or usable and
as a result municipalities are
Contracting out to
either build new playgrounds or
substantially redesign
um and rebuild existing playgrounds
relying on the representations provided
to them by contractors and those they
contract with to provide advice and as
you've heard in in Windham and in other
locations uh the result is they're
installing playgrounds that don't comply
with the Ada they'll be notified that
they don't comply and then they're
having to go back and redo that in order
to avoid lawsuits so that's all I have
I'm happy to answer any questions
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Mr Grace so my
question pertains to
um the use the specification
specification of the use of resilient
rubber or urethane rubber calm composite
surfacing so my I'm wondering with
regards to this bill are you aware of
any research that was done that takes in
that considers the environmental impacts
of the use of these materials and I
asked that because in my town Brookline
there is a playground on a beach which
is literally within feet of a lake so I
have concerns with this and and those
impacts so I actually called the sponsor
and asked her a very similar question
and she pointed out that the line
continues or similar resilient solid
safe material so you could pick another
material other than those those were
just her preference I also pointed out
that um the EPA and various
appropriate federal agencies are doing
an ongoing study on crumb rubber infill
which is a type of surface material that
may be used that may have health impacts
there's no result of that yet it's just
an ongoing study so I I flagged that in
in the fiscal note as well just to make
that aware but
unfortunately there's there's a positive
and negatives with with any of these
okay uh representative
thank you thank you Mr chairman um short
question
do you think this is necessary
where Federal requirements are buried
within Federal rules and regulations so
that it's hard for the average uh select
board member to find them I think that
it would be appropriate to incorporate
those into state law thank you
representative Kelly thank you thank you
for taking the question isn't
um this law more restrictive than the
federal guidelines in that there are
some things that would be loose
um
like the engineer would products that
would not be allowed under this because
it's not loose in this this law is
requiring a solid surface
thank you so
under atsm 1951 as I understand it that
may be an appropriate surfacing material
but only in certain uses so it may be
the case is in New Hampshire where our
weather affects how that material
stays or comes together after initially
constructed and requires ongoing
maintenance that
it may no longer be a qualified material
under the federal guidelines which is
where municipalities run into trouble as
representative Gallagher
um so
uh one further follow-up on the state
federal law
distinction so
um
if the Americans with Disabilities Act
Were Somehow repealed at the federal
level this legislation would still take
yes I believe that's the case
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you Mr chairs uh in the
blue sheet I have three individuals
signed up looks like two out of the
three spoke in favor
and with that will close the hearing on
HP 467 our next hearing begins in 15
hmm
he's probably not to come up with it
yeah we have it we have it
okay welcome back everybody I'm gonna
open up the hearing
hb335 relative to notice of tax lien on
real estate
subject to a lien for old age assistant
representative Cahill welcome to
Municipal and County Government
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee I am representative
Michael Cahill of Newmarket I represent
Rockingham 10 the towns of newfields and
Newmarket and it's uh nice to be here
with you today uh this is this bill
we're here because uh in the last term a
constituent asked me to file a bill to
extend the deadline for the other lanes
other liens covered by
RSA 80 colon 65 which we did this
happened in the Judiciary but this year
we're in Municipal but that's fine
and it sailed through without objection
and uh but apparently we missed one and
that would be why we're here today to
deal with RSA 80 colon 68.
and this is the reason is the same in
that they are there are only a few
people uh doing this sort of work and
they need a bit more time so we were
asking you to extend the deadline on
this particular one by the same 15 days
bringing it from 45 to 60. you have
testimony from my constituent and I've
also brought you the uh the bill from
last time and on the reverse side of
that is the testimony and support of
that bill from the municipal Association
and uh perhaps explaining it more
thoroughly than I can the reason why
I see no questions representative Cahill
very well uh I'm not going to push them
out or anything I have no further pink
cards
on the blue sheet I have two individuals
close the hearing on HP 335 thank you
sir
okay we have 10 minutes until we begin
Okay one minute warning folks
before we get going uh I'm going to ask
the anybody who's intending to testify
please limit your testimony to three
minutes we have a lot of cards on this
bill
if somebody before you makes the point
please do not reiterate it
and other than that we will go ahead and
open up the hearing on House Bill 423
relative to accessory dwelling unit uses
Allowed by right representative Reed
welcome back thank you Mr chair and
thank you honorable members of the
committee once again for my for the
record my name is Ellen Reed and I
represent Rockingham 10 that's New
Market in new fields and I do hope the
chair will be kind with me about any
three-minute limit because I'm
introducing the bill
um you all obviously know what accessory
dwelling units are a few years back and
I do believe it was a republican
sponsored Bill uh a bill passed and
became law saying that we have one Adu
little kind of in-law apartment buy
right for every homeowner
um
my constituent reached out to me a few
years ago he was attempting to build an
in-law unit in his detached garage
completely contained within the detached
garage the law had allowed towns to
limit
the Adu that was allowed by Wright to
being only attached and my town had done
so and interpreted that word attached to
mean it had to actually be attached to
the primary building and not contained
within any other pre-existing building
even though those buildings had already
gotten approved by the town their
Footprints were there you're not adding
to the footprint and my constituent
rightfully pointed out to me
um and everybody actually that in a
housing crisis and this was several
years ago when the housing crisis was
nowhere near as severe as it is now that
we should not be limiting
homeowners from creating what is in
essence affordable yet very frequently
high quality housing so rather than
being in a kind of large builder-grade
low-income apartment building like we
frequently talk about people building
this allows people to build onto their
own uh houses and those tend to be when
they're building on their own homes tend
to be higher quality and they maintain
them better and usually those people are
people who have a normal job and they're
just working so why are we preventing
this kind of decentralized uh kind of
victory garden approach to increasing
affordable but high quality Supply that
we desperately need so I went to my town
planner at the time who's no longer my
town planner and I may have said this in
the previous testimony ball repeated
when I when I told her I didn't like the
fact that we were prohibiting this
because this helps homeowners and it
helps tenants and it's really one of
those rare moments that actually does
that
um she told me those people meaning
people who needed low-income housing
those people we do enough for those
people they have the trailers and the
apartments
I told her that I was indeed one of
those people
um the other thing about adus is that
you can create adus and not impact rural
character certainly my constituent
putting an Adu inside of a completely
detached structure would not have been
obvious to anybody passing on the street
that that was occupied by somebody you
don't know it just looks like a house
with a garage on some land very lovely
rural character that we talk about
preserving
um I do serve on the special housing
committee and one of the things that has
already become very apparent on that
committee is that the area that onerous
Town restrictions that prevents
Solutions such as this
um they went after even I think things
that towns would have a harder time
swallowing like lot minimums and what
have you but this is a really easy thing
this is simply extending uh the right we
have to 180u to two adus and it does a
couple other things too I did work with
two different town planners the town
planner of my town of Newmarket as well
as an adjoining town in a different
County Durham to draft this language
and I also worked with the municipal
Association to draft the language which
was the real hard get as you can imagine
um so just to go through the bones of
the bill this does expand by right to
two adus it does redefine what attach
means to include not just sharing a part
of a wall with the primary resonance but
also completely contained within a
pre-existing pre-approved structure
that's detached from the primary
structure so again if the town's already
approved that footprint there's no
reason the town should be limiting
people from having an apartment in that
in that structure
it uh it does remove the re the the
ability for the town to require on one
unit
uh that it be attached so if a person
chooses to have one Adu it may be
attached or detached but if it does
allow the town to require one unit be
attached if that person then has another
unit
so I may end up saying second unit it
just understand second unit doesn't mean
chronologically the second unit it's not
the second unit being built
chronologically it means if a person has
two units one is allowed something and
the other one is allowed to be
restricted
it increases the existing square footage
the the amount that a town can restrict
the square footage of an Adu down to so
right now a town can restrict an huge um
to no no less no less than 750 square
feet this raises that up to a thousand
the reason that's important is because
what we're attempting to do is create
supply of long-term sustainable housing
and you can't do that
um for you know with just small
apartments around a thousand square feet
is when you can kind of have a small
family or a couple with a dog if you're
only restricting to 750 square feet that
means you're basically limited to like
college kids or single people for as
long as they're single you're looking at
more short-term tenants that are only
going to stay there for a year or two
years rather than that longer term
investment in that community that we're
we're looking to achieve
it it brings that up to a thousand
square feet for one unit any other unit
may be restricted down to 850 square
feet
in the current existing long and I want
I want to be very very clear nothing in
this bill
uh touches restricts the one Adu we have
by right I was very adamant that we had
to leave every right that we have in
place for that first Adu in place if
there is an additional Adu that this is
creating the right for there are a few
things that the town can restrict for
the additional Adu but not the first Adu
that's been allowed by right again
that's not chronological it's the number
of Adas you have so for any additional
it's 850 square feet that a town May
restrict the size down to if you have
more than one Adu these Town may require
that you have a lot minimum of no more
than a half of an acre
and uh towns can uh the I already
covered the attached piece so they can't
require that one be attached but they
can require if you have an additional
one that that be attached and then the
last piece in the piece that I will say
that the municipal Association was
particularly fond of if someone Builds
an additional Adu then the town can
tell that uh just like they would with
say like a an apartment building project
they can say that one has to meet our
Workforce housing formula and thereby
allow the towns to count that unit
towards their Workforce housing
requirement so that's kind of the bones
of the entire bill
but I just to Circle back around to the
importance of adus not only is it this
decentralized kind of victory card and
approach to creating Supply that ends up
being way uh
way better for land landowners because
it helps them buy or stay in their homes
and I'm the ideal the gold standard
would be home ownership we want people
to be able to own homes because that
home ownership rates increased
homeownership rates uh improve basically
every metric of a town if you can have a
little apartment off to the side you can
get that rental income and afford to buy
a home and that's what towns ideally
would like
but also so it helps people stay in
their homes helps people buy homes but
it really creates a really healthy much
healthier environment on average than
large Builder grade apartment complexes
as someone who's lived in apartments my
entire life I can tell you I know that
there's people who don't want apartment
complexes in their neighborhood I think
we do need to address density for sure
but I can tell you A lot of those places
aren't a blast to live in either for
most people you would rather live in
someone's Adu because it's not kind of a
corporate landlord it's just a you know
a person with the job and you can use
their backyard and maybe negotiate that
you can have a dog or you know a garden
or whatever it just and fosters that
personal relationship in that community
and helps people be happier for longer
um
I'm happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony
representative priest
thank you Mr chairman just for
clarification thank you for taking my
question of course representative
um so let's pretend that we have a
existing structure and under the current
Adu law they
divided their house into two units
and one was being the Adu right under
this law would they be able to build
another unit detached on their property
so there would be three units correct
okay so yes so um because in your
example you described a situation where
that current unit that they already had
was already attached
um this bill allows at least one of the
units to be detached and so they would
be allowed to have a detached unit
whether completely contained within well
that counts as attached to but they
could be contained within a detached
garage or built entirely separately
yeah
representative Holland
um so uh I let's suppose I didn't have I
have a lot a house on say one acre lot I
didn't have the fourth saw forethought
or lock to have a detached garage uh
currently by right I'm only allowed to
do an attached Adu I would not be able
to do a a a detached Adu by right so my
question is why not just allow in this
bill a detached Adu to be allowed by
right it is
and if if it's not let me um sorry
question follow-up so in other words I
don't it appears under here that in
order to have the detached Adu I have to
have a pre-existing structure so that
counts no that counts as attached now
so previously completely contained
within a detached structure counted
apparently for most towns interpretation
as detached I am saying that that counts
as attached and in addition you are
allowed by right one detached unit
which would be a standalone unit
the questions representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question we have a bill in
this committee House Bill 44 which is
the four Plex bill
if that bill were to pass could we have
could each one of those have an two ad
use
no I do not believe that's the case
because first of all the bills are
substantively different in that that
bill only impacts Municipal City and
water this is for everyone and and
obviously the more you get out of
Municipal and City Water you have larger
Lots anyway
my understanding is that that ability to
have a four Plex in one lot that that
would still count toward that this would
be counted as that so it would increase
that to four on those Municipal and City
Water Lots
um instead of like three essentially is
what we're doing here but that those
would essentially be counted as that if
um if there's a different interpretation
of law we can certainly address that in
an amendment
or the questions representative Kelly
thank you so my understanding of your
explanation was that adus the difference
between Adu and a separate unit kind of
like a duplex versus the Adu is
essentially the same and so you so if
you have a duplex and an Adu then you're
technically have three a kind of a three
Plex is that your interpretation
so that the ID so adus are kind of
subordinate whereas duplexes and and
cottages and all of that are kind of
Standalone the Standalone is kind of
bigger and more onerous than an Adu and
so if you're building one of those it's
as if you've built an Adu plus right
kind of in a way to think about it so if
you're the threshold for building an Adu
is lower so if you've jumped that up to
you know a separate unit entirely like a
cottage or whatever then it's not that
each one of those gets their own the
other piece of that is that on a lot of
the municipal City and water lots that
are being discussed in that other Bill
those lots will be under the half acre
that towns are allowed to require in
this bill so they towns could say no
your lot is too small to allow an Adu
brother further questions
representative 11.
thank you Mr chair thanks uh
representative Reed for coming to
testify
I'm all about the Adu I got to tell you
my question is
it's going to sound weird can an Adu be
attached to an Adu
I don't believe that's a lot were you
not done I will expand and just yeah go
ahead so I have a single family home
I build an Adu that's not attached
and I want to build another Adu can I
attach it to my Adu or do I have to
attach it to my house
so
it has to be oh I see so are you
building like to
um that would so that the town in that
case would be allowed to require that it
be attached to your primary dwelling the
second one in this bill again happy to
address that I will just say I'm very
happy to hear you're all about the adus
because one of the things I forgot to
mention was that they really are life
cycle housing because as an adult you
buy a house you decide in order to buy a
house the only way you can afford is to
build an Adu so you build an Adu maybe
you rent it out to or first you might
build it just for your elderly parent
but then when your elderly elderly
parent moves on you might rent it out to
a college student then when your kids
are old enough for college they might
rent it then you might move into your
own you answered the question a long
time ago representative mangaputi
lifecycle housing
Mr chair the question is for you I'm one
of the co-sponsors am I allowed to ask
questions I'm not testifying so is I
know it's either or you may ask
questions as long as you are not
testifying thank you
um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Reed for bringing this uh
bill
my question is
how would this enhance the co-op
opportunity in terms of co-owning a
property so you know
how would that enhance a building
density as well as improving
so I don't think you thank you for the
question I don't see it legally like
addressing Co-op issues but socially
speaking it provides more opportunities
because if you have two adus on a
property now you've got two tenants
maybe the the original owner wants to
sell now you've got two tenants they're
able to split the cost of buying that
property together so and then maybe they
get a third person for the main unit or
you know somehow work that out whereas
if you only have one Adu it's either
that person can buy your entire property
or they can't
representative ukella
thank you you were talking about
um kind of like Aging in place
essentially as far as like your your
situation changing can you expand it
more upon that thank you so much for the
question so as I was saying as you might
decide that you need to build an Adu for
your aging parent when they move on you
might rent it out for your college
student then when your kids become old
enough maybe transitionally in between
moving out they rent your unit then they
move out you may decide as you're aging
you move into your own Adu for a smaller
space rent out for you know after you're
retired you have less income rent out
the main unit instead of renting out the
Adu and it just kind of goes like that
right so it's it's it it it really plays
into our natural life cycle to have kind
of an accessory unit
if you were a child of us of the 60s
would you call that a commune
so no
um
and I'm a child of children of the 60s
so any further questions you answered
the question you said no representative
thank you Mr chair
um and thanks for the moment of levity
are you aware of how many towns have
enacted a clear Adu ordinance in their
town since the original Adu law was
passed I ask because I discovered that
my town of Dover has a very unclear Adu
and basically the only way you can get
one is getting a variance and it's
annoying which uh thank you for the
question
comment and uh I was not aware that it
sounds like from just your description
Dover may not be doing it right because
they are guaranteed by right
um but anyhow other towns is really what
I'm interested so I don't know about
other towns I know about my town and
that my town chose to take the state up
on limiting to only attached and that
they've determined that for them
attachment not including completely
contained within a pre-existing
structure thank you further questions so
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um with regard to adus is there anything
in statute that restricts or limits the
the the occupants to be
um family related
currently
uh no in fact
there was some
if I and this is a while ago since I
worked with OLS on this but there was
some
um reference to
like family but it's not restricting it
further questions representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
can you tell me the source of the um
square footage that's adequate for uh
size of demographics that you're looking
to fit it was a compromise between me
and the town planners and especially the
town planner Durham thank you
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
and my apologies if this has been asked
and answered before
but since this is not a bill dealing
with areas that are served by public
water and sewer
presumably so if it passes some of these
adus will be in areas served by septic
what if the septic is inadequate to
serve the additional adus thank you so
much for the question that is actually
addressed in in the existing RSA which I
did not change so the only way a town is
allowed to deny an attached Adu under
750 square feet at this moment is if it
doesn't uh the the existing water and
septic is not up to what is necessary
for those that number of bedrooms so the
person would have to improve their water
and septic in order to build that's
currently the case for adus and we did
not change that so if you're building
additional Adu your water and septic
still need to to meet the requirement
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking a second question
um in uh I guess it's line 26 number
three there is a change to existing law
with the interior door went from a shell
to a may I know you I know you said this
but I'm not 100 clear on why that is now
optional that was another request of the
Town planners they they themselves did
not think that in that requiring an
interior door was necessary adus have
their own separate entrances so thank
you
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you so much
hi so
um yeah most most of you should know me
as representative Eric Gallagher um so I
um
I'm doing the opposite of Representative
mangaputi where I'm testifying instead
of asking questions
um I think representative Reed did a
pretty good job covering the legal
aspects of the text of the bill so I
just kind of want to add a personal
story here
um so I'm currently in a long distance
relationship my fiance and I met online
and
um she lives in New Jersey I live here
in in New Hampshire and one of the
reasons we haven't been able to
move in together is just because
housing is so hard to find
so
um her her dream
for
dream house has always been to have
um
a property with separate dwellings on it
for each of her close closest family
members in other words 80 years so and
in
New Jersey
they're actually they don't even have an
Adu law
um
so they don't allow any adus by right
um so
um yeah I think
I think passing this here in New
Hampshire she she still probably want to
live in New Jersey anyways since that's
closer to where her family is
um
but I I do think so yeah this wouldn't
directly benefit us
um but I think it could at least Inspire
other states we have to be thinking
about how we're not the only state with
the housing crisis here and we have an
opportunity to show leadership us to
what is possible
with pro-housing legislation for other
states that are also experiencing their
own housing crisis is
um so yeah I think that is an important
reason to support this bill
representative
thank you thank you for testifying um it
seemed to me that your your story was
essentially saying that you would
um be able to like if this passed that
it would be essentially an attractive
benefit of New Hampshire that might
encourage people
maybe your significant other maybe
others to move to New Hampshire because
of the way that they want to
um you know age in place
yeah it'd be a factor to consider
um a you know different different
families could wait different
um factors
um different amounts so
um while in my particular case the
wanting to be the close to family might
um overpower there might be other cases
where that wouldn't necessarily be the
case and they would want to move here
representative man chapudi thank you Mr
chair thank you uh representative
Gallagher for taking my question
um
would you consider this would be a
benefit in terms of intergenerational
living opportunities so Aging in place
um yeah definitely
um you know I I think
having a separate space for
different generations
of uh think of a single family can be
pretty important especially when say the
children are adults and the parents are
older like when I when I moved back to
New Hampshire
um
and I I first moved back in with my
parents and
um there were a lot of
um conflicts between between us at just
having to share the same living space
again so I think yeah being able to
um
have separate Living Spaces could help
resolve
help families live more harmoniously
together
seeing no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony next we're going
there we go thank you Mr chair and
committee I appreciate the opportunity
my name is Sarah Holland and I am a
realtor and I'm the vice chair of the
public policy committee for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors and
I'm there
um I am here on their behalf as well as
my own I absolutely love this bill
so
um New Hampshire housing crisis is real
we all know that I'm not going to
belabor the stats there
um and I love the term life cycle
housing because really that brings us to
the stories the real life stories of
people that we know and we love and the
plights that they have of finding
housing in the event of well my my son
is 21 when he's done with college
housing where does he go does he come
home with me probably not a great idea
but where is he going to go
um in the case of my parents who are
aging maybe it makes sense for them to
move closer to me or in with me or for
folks who happen to have
um a relationship that falls apart where
does one of those parties go all of
these are contributing to the housing
crisis that we have in New Hampshire and
we seem to be taking the existing
inventory that we have now and moving
around those those tortoise shells and
that doesn't solve our problem it just
shifts everything it looks like maybe
we're doing something but we're not
exactly
so this bill
um
creates inventory it creates more
inventory and it provides Clarity and
additional opportunity from the original
Adu bill by allowing
um
additional adus in places that are fully
contained
existing structures so for example my
situation I live in a small subdivision
about 12 houses they were all built in
the 80s we're all on one acre lots and
all of the houses are exactly the same
the only difference half of US have
attached garages the other ones they're
detached garages the town that I live in
in order to have an Adu and a detached
garage or a detached structure I need to
increase my one acre to five acres and I
don't know how I'm going to be able to
do that so this would really solve a
problem for me as all of our children
are now you know they've been out in the
world and they're going to come home for
a short time and land for a little bit
figure out where their what their next
step is in life and I don't want them in
my space anymore
and also as we're aging and I am looking
to maybe downsize putting a smaller unit
above my garage for provides an
opportunity for me to live in a smaller
space without living moving from the
place that I have called home for so
long but allowing my children and maybe
their spouse and their children to come
home and occupy the additional space
that we we currently reside in in
addition to that there I have numerous
stories and numerous clients and
consumer consumers that I talk with on a
daily basis that
really need some temporary housing in
between situations
um maybe they just graduated from
college they want to stay in their
current job they can't yet afford to
purchase a home or where they're moving
next there's some sort of Gap in time
that they need to cover we have family
friends whose kids are still residing in
their home they want them to move on
they can't because there is no place for
them to go my apartment over my garage
which is not yet built but will be
thanks to your passing of this bill
um will allow them to come to that safe
space as well
so I think that there are some really
great opportunities with this bill to
create the much needed inventory in a
very safe space as well
um
and we've seen with the current
accessory unit dwelling unit law that
was passed in 2016. a lot of the
concerns that were raised there really
have not materialized and we know that
local control is super important and
everyone takes it seriously however it's
important to remember that the state has
mandated numerous items on communities
besides adus
yes
well over the oh sorry a lot of time I'm
pretty sure we understand where you're
going with this anybody have any
questions representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh I have with this bill
there's no requirement for being on
Municipal and water and sewer so this
can expand out from the middle of town
so if you have a compact
uh center of town and as you get further
out there's more space in rural
character do you think that this bill
would start to fill in those places and
the rural character of a community would
would become less desirable
I would say I would say no so I actually
come from an area of the state where
Community sewer and water are fairly
non-existent
um so this would provide an opportunity
we we are all very much part of this
housing crisis and folks just want to be
in safe living situations
um and feel part of a community so if
you can do that by adding an additional
unit to your existing house or two
additional units to your existing house
I think that they're um
thought there is a huge need for that
and I think that that wouldn't become an
issue relative to the sewer and water
there is Provisions in here as
previously stated by representative
reach
I will ask those testifying to please
try to remain on to the question asked
please representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question we we have a
housing crisis we passed a bill to allow
an Adu so my question is how did passage
of that bill help our housing crisis in
so much as how will increasing it from
one to two help our housing crisis and I
couldn't find a stat on that that's why
I'm asking the question yeah absolutely
so only from my personal experience and
I also do not have a stat relative to
that however
it didn't help my situation and I'm
hoping that this language change will
help my situation
representative representative yokella
thank you thank you for
you know thank you for taking the
question
um
under the current law
um they defined attached very narrowly
to actually being attached with the with
the main structure and not
um in existing structures that you
already inhabit and
um can you talk a little bit about how
maybe that might not be appropriate for
every situation and and how existing
um transforming an existing structure
doesn't really
um wouldn't necessarily change the
character of the uh Community thanks
absolutely so with my own personal
example so we do have an existing
structure we have our detached garage so
nothing would change there and if you're
thinking about the dynamic of the people
that are already on my property it just
kind of spreads us out a little bit so
the the rural nature the character of
our community utilizing these structures
that may become much better maintained
because they are now being inhabited by
somebody else I think is is a benefit
representative hit
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question so some of our
municipalities are struggling with
short-term rentals
in your experience in your profession
do you see that this is a potential
problem that somebody will
build an Adu and rent it out to one of
those companies it is possible if there
are no restrictions in place and I know
that that's definitely something that's
being
yes it's um relative to the workforce
housing associated with that third unit
then there are some restrictions that
are in place for that
um but
yeah the towns would have the ability to
to create representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and I'm going to shift
towards not building more housing to
address the crisis how would this impact
the revenue in terms of taxes to the
Townsend municipalities yeah they would
be additional living spaces so it would
be a benefit for the town and I know
that there is some concern on the the
part of the town for them to be to add
additional draws on the municipal
resources but that would be compensated
by the taxation of those units
okay so you know more questions thank
you very much for your testimony next
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
committee members my name is Ben Frost
I'm the deputy executive director and
chief legal officer at New Hampshire
housing
it was my pleasure in 2016 to work with
this Committee in the development of the
now existing accessory dwelling unit law
and it's my pleasure to be before you
again
the term housing crisis has been invoked
here to put a finer point on it New
Hampshire housing will publish this
month a Statewide housing needs
assessment that estimates that New
Hampshire will need to produce over the
next 20 years something on the order of
80 to 100
000 housing units
to meet growth and changes in household
composition
that's a lot of Housing and we're not
building at that rate right now
the existing accessory dwelling unit law
was an incremental step forward and
House Bill 423 also presents an
incremental step forward
it will not solve the problem alone but
as part of
a much broader Suite of solutions so I
encourage your your consideration of
this
um what it does really is
enable Property Owners to use their
property
more broadly than they currently can
it gives them greater right to use their
property as they see fit Within
reasonable restrictions exercised by
municipalities
and it does this without a single penny
of public subsidy and this is something
really important to bear in mind as the
legislature is considering a great
variety of Appropriations relative to
housing this session
this is a a solution that does not
require Public Funding simply relies on
property owners
to do what they want with their
properties within the bounds of their
local regulations
I'm happy to take any questions Mr
chairman
representative
Mr chair and thank you Mr Frost for
being here today
I have a question about wording in the
bill and in line 13 on page one of the
bill
it says two accessory dwelling units
shall be allowed without additional
requirements and then if you go to the
next page to line 34 there's a reference
to two or more accessory drilling units
I'm confused by that
if this is only allowing two why would
it say two or more well if they want to
allow more than two uh with House Bill
423 would require them to allow two a
municipality may choose to do more than
that
representative man chapudi
thank you Mr T thank you for taking my
question how would this address the
current waiting list for senior housing
uh you know other demographic there's a
long waiting list for housing because
there's no inventory how would this
address at least partially I know it's
not a solution do you think it would
well that's a great question
representative Manchester at the as I
said and I'll I'll repeat what I said
seven years ago
the bill then and the bill now would not
in my estimation create a tidal wave of
development but rather we would see very
incremental development and in fact that
has been the response to the accessory
dwelling unit law adopted by the
legislature and enacted in 2016. it's
been lot by lot here and there and I
know there was one question
and I forget who asked it about the the
number of
representative imaginary might have been
you the number of units produced there's
no
real clear measure of that because
there's no one keeping track of that
you'd have to go to each municipality
and go through the building permit
records to get to how many have been
produced I think
we have seen now I will tell you
anecdotally I talked with the planners
in Portsmouth and Merrimack and they see
a dozen here a dozen they're not a huge
number of of units produced but
incremental development further
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr chairman uh next we have uh Nate
Grace
thank you Mr chair and H craze for the
municipal Association we do oppose this
bill I do want to thank the sponsor for
reaching out and accommodating some of
our suggestions to moderate the bill but
it's still a Statewide zoning mandate
and we oppose Statewide zoning mandates
um we are obviously concerned that this
would decrease the ability of
municipalities to regulate the type of
growth that occurs
um within their boundaries and regulate
their type of character and therefore we
would oppose this bill and have to take
any questions that the community may
have
thank you for your testimony any further
questions
thank you as the previous fake speaker
spoke about how people were
um
uh wanting to use their property and be
have this flexibility
um
and it's not a tidal wave but but
incremental of each individual person
giving giving uh kind of their consent
to say use their property in the way
that they want
um how do you feel that it is the um
that the restricting of municipalities
on those people's property
um rights is is
um
contributing I guess to the housing
crisis
that that we that the state is facing
thank you I I don't think that's the
major driving Factor but I I don't think
that's relevant to the build language so
I'm thinking that your chair is going to
further questions representative got
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question do you see
uh could you would you comment please on
the unintended consequences that this
bill would result in particularly the
impact it might have on the overall
zoning in each community
in the future
sure so uh
if so property rights are really uh
often described in the law as a bundle
of sticks where you have different
rights that are kind of in this this
pile and we give up some of those uh
under planning and zoning laws so that
we can come together as a community and
plan collectively
um and so part of the unintended
consequences that would occur for this
is we'd have less ability for something
like the master plan to help direct what
the what the growth is of the community
it would be more an individual
individual lot by lot basis which would
uh make it more difficult for the
municipality to anticipate what kinds of
needs will occur in the future
hey thank you Mr chairman representative
priest
thank you Mr chairman um I'm confused
um because I I don't see any mandates
that a property owner has to do this so
by saying that this is an unfended
mandate I I don't see it can you uh
enlighten me
well it's a land use mandate because it
would restrict the
municipalities ability to adopt or
continue to have a zoning code that
would limit the number of units dwelling
units on a on a property by mandating
that they have allow up to two instead
of just one as current
I hope that made sense but you're
looking more confused
you have a follow-up as a follow-up go
ahead do you believe that the existing
zoning that restricts the number of
units per lot is basically
in a way
um discriminatory because you're
basically
limiting the use of those lots and
um you're taking away the rights of the
property owner
I think there was a question in there
there was a question
see none thank you for your testimony
the last pink card I have on this bill
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Alyssa margolin
and I serve as director of housing
action New Hampshire where Statewide
Coalition of 80 organizations United on
affordable housing policy and ending
homelessness in New Hampshire our
members are those who developed Finance
manage affordable housing properties
public housing agencies homeless service
agencies and Supportive Housing agencies
they are indeed key Partners as we all
try to climb our way out of this very
severe housing crisis thank you for
considering expanding New Hampshire's
existing Adu law housing action New
Hampshire
is in strong support of this bill
um many of the key points have been made
by prior testifiers
um what I thought I would do is just
share with you our perspective we were
one of the many organizations who came
together in 2015 and 2016 to pass SB 146
and it was a real coming together many
folks were very concerned about property
rights and had been battling often at
the local level about how to address
family needs particularly around caring
for aging parents and dealing with adult
children with disabilities in fact our
governor at the time who signed this Adu
law in in the ad SB 146 into law had
experienced that herself right she had
to find a town that would accommodate
her to to provide housing for her adult
son with disabilities so we had come
together with AARP and the DD council at
the time
and property rights organizations to
make the arguments that created the Adu
law
and it even despite very low interest
rates and essentially easy access to
funds we have seen a sprinkling of adus
kind of throughout the state where it
made sense at this point we don't have
conclusive data on what the impact was
but I know that the concerns that were
raised at the time during you know the
thoughtful debate that we had that would
be we would create an Airbnb disaster
particularly in the Taurus regions never
never materialized I live in the city of
Portsmouth I can just tell you
anecdotally my neighbor wanted to
convert her Barn it was detached she was
denied by the city after Adu law passed
it she was successful and provided a
home for her aging dad her dad has
recently passed away and a neighbor's
parent is now living in the converted
barn and so I urge you to support the
expansion of our very successful Adu law
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you
representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh we've heard from a previous
a witness and now I've heard again from
you we have a sprinkling of adus I'm
again trying to get to how how does
increasing to two help us and I'm
wondering then if you might think that
what we'll have is multiple units on
those multiple Lots rather than a
proliferation throughout the state does
that make any sense I I do I mean I I
don't know that we can really anticipate
that right it's really depends on what
the what a family's needs are and
um and and what they decide to build and
so far we haven't seen kind of a mass
build out I will say from housing action
New Hampshire's point of view I mean
most of our members are multi-family
developers you know we don't see this as
the magic solution for dealing with the
80 to 100
000 you know units that the state's
going to need over the next 20 years but
we do think it's gentle density we do
think that it is
um
it's a way for communities to really
Embrace
providing this housing and particularly
you know one of our challenges really as
an affordable housing Coalition is some
of the adus that are developed are not
affordable right I mean they're they're
market rate or more but they take the
pressure off of the market in a way so
say for example your family with means
and you have an adult child with
disabilities and you don't want to put
them in the system you can provide
at-home care and uh you know and and
keep them on your property and care for
them instead of um you know putting them
in a system with you know in some kind
of a group service scenario and then
that leaves room for other folks who
representative
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question
um
um do you think that uh some of the
reason that there's only a sprinkling
um might have to do with this detect
this definition of attached which is now
get going to be more uh allowing for the
people that previous like the people
that previously testified about they
have a structure that is that um that is
existing that they may uh be able to put
someone in
um that may not be attached because they
don't want to share a wall maybe
necessarily but they have you know a
garage and so that would open up the
um this law to maybe a wider audience
than than the current existing law I see
thank you for the question
representative I think I understand your
question my understanding is when we
passed SB 146 you know uh the the state
said that a municipalities ordinance
must at least provide for an attached
but if the municipality wanted to they
could do detached and for example in the
city of Portsmouth they do allow for
detached and they're I think
theoretically yes I mean if the state
enhances the current statute to say the
municipality must also allow for
detached you would be freeing up the
property owner and their rights to do
with what they want with their property
to you know and maybe that flexibility
would be more of an incentive for them
representative Guthrie thank you Mr
chairman for letting me have a question
again
I think I missed something and maybe you
can help me with
uh water and sewer
did I miss that did we just
what impact does this do in communities
that don't have
water
and have septic systems and you're
doubling
the size of the home was on the lot
but and originally it was probably
brought in into account that was weighed
in to their ability to build
and now you're just saying hey doesn't
mean any different make any difference
we can double that
um thank you for the question
representative I I don't think you
missed it and I I I probably am not the
right witness to really testify as to
the technical aspects but I think when
this came up in 2015 and 2016 it's kind
of no different than if your aunt came
to live within your home or you had a
new baby or you know you're adding just
like it's a very gentle density so I
think that the consensus at the time was
it's not very taxing
um on if you have septic or or you know
the current water sewer infrastructure
that I think that that helps a lot thank
you very much thank you representative
second Mr chair thank you for taking my
question would this help the sandwich
generation where you're caring for your
children maybe in a child with
disability as well as the aging parent
and trying to navigate to this would
give an opportunity for a sandwich
generation to have that ability to live
in one place with adus you thank you for
the question representative um indeed
the much of the political momentum in
2015 and 2016 was this coming together
of both this concern this human concern
for caring for uh for folks given how
few choices we have in the state around
housing and the desire to do what one
wants to do with their own property I
will say that I believe some water sewer
languages is in the in the bill at the
top of page two and so I'll just refer
you to that representative Guthrie
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you
last pink card we have on that bill I
have the blue sign up sheet I have uh
let's see six people who signed in four
against and two four
and with that we'll close the hearing on
HB 423
I will be introducing the next bill so
represent Vice chair power will be the
chairman
oops
well I see a dog with
I do I see a Scotty
the time is 2 43 and I will open the
hearing on House Bill 270 relative to
the election of Stratford County
Commissioners
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative turcotte to introduce the
bill
thank you madam chair indeed
representative Len turcotte current
representative for Stratford County
District 4 which are the towns of
Barrington and Stratford currently in my
fourth term I served three terms on
labor last year I served on labor
finance and more importantly the special
committee on redistricting that happens
I've passed out a handout I would have
loved to have it for you in color it
makes it a lot easier to read
Unfortunately they won't reproduce that
here so
I different Shades of Gray for you I'll
get into those a little bit later along
with the attach sheet which is a little
bit of data I'll explain that as I go
along
so Stratford county is the only County
within the state there are 10 counties
it's the only County where we elect
three Commissioners at large rather than
electing them by commissioner districts
and the
RSA that talks about that 662-4 and it
says except for Stratford County where
three Commissioners shall be elected at
large for the purpose of choosing County
Commissioners the county shall be
divided into districts and follows as
follows and that goes into a list of
each individual County
and how they those commissioner
as I said last term I served on the
special committee for redistricting and
we had actually intended and discussed
including this in the 10-year
redistricting plan but we thought that
it might kind of throw a little bit of
too much into the process many of you
might have known the data came into us
about six seven months later than it was
supposed to due to the covid so we were
kind of rushed and we just didn't want
this interfering with the redistricting
process that that we had to deal with
already
so what we did is we decided we'd wait
and introduce it this term
what we did during redistricting last
time is we actually went around
to every County and held what we called
listening sessions where we took
comments from the public every County we
just we went to their counties and
listened
and almost unanimously I think I was
able to attend eight of the 10 hearings
and the the one issue we heard over and
over and over is and we were there
mainly for uh redistricting of uh County
State reps but also for the
Commissioners but everybody the one
thing that we wrote down time after time
was fairness they wanted to see maps
that were Fair
I think in at least in terms of the
current State Rep
distribution of 201 to 198 I I'm not
sure we could have drawn maps that were
much more fair
but what we have in Stratford county is
just the opposite of that we do not have
uh fairness in our County and the reason
is
when you elect
at large in a County
that is
for sake of argument I'll give you the
exact numbers later but 60 40 Democrat
three Commissioners that come out of
that election every two years are three
Democrats
and as long as I've been around the
majority of those have come from the
cities of Dover Rochester
and Somersworth
so not only does this disenfranchise and
in this case in the in the case of
fairness for the Republic for the lack
of Republicans on the commissioners
um
in the commissioner's office and also
disenfranchises the voters
in our County we have Durham Madbury Lee
Barrington Stratford New Durham
Farmington Middleton and Milton
that becomes second thoughts
when dealing with County issues
I believe there are going to be some
testifying today that are going to speak
more to that point so I'm not going to
get into
some of those reasonings and let them do
so now I want to talk a little bit about
the the data well actually first
um yeah let's talk about the data first
so on the current map that that I handed
out uh that when you look at that map
it'll say D1 D2 D3 those are the
districts that are being proposed in
the current map is based on
of course the
2020 census data
and
this map here would have resulted based
on the 2022 election in a roughly 60 40
split if you go to the data page
and you look in the lower right hand
district one it says total r
there were 20
based on the 22 2022 election
there were 23 589 R's in District One
there were 22 276 votes cast for
democrats for a split of 51.4 to
48.6 So based on the 2022 election you
would have had a republican win district
one
by roughly 3 percent
if you go to District 2 which that's the
one that's kind of highlighted in the
the
the the thick line there
um
in that District
15057 our votes 38
167 D Depot so you can see in that uh
District if that would have existed in
2022 that would actually been a 28.3
percent Republican 71.7 percent uh
Democrats so that would have been a
Democrat seat and then in the final
District three uh again I won't read the
exact numbers but it was a 45 to 54
split that would have also been a
Democrat seat so based on 2022 election
data you would have ended up with to
Democrat Commissioners and one
Republican which again uh is more
representative of the actual County of
Stratford you look down that the last
number below there you'll see
county-wide the county-wide vote totals
were 41.3 Republican and 58.7 for the
Democrats
now in drawing the the map itself
as I said I was on the redistricting
committee my main focus last time around
was on the House of Representatives
districts there were other individuals
that their main um
Focus was the Commissioners but on this
one
you'll you'll notice that
there are
when you draw any kind of a map there's
certain things that you have to maintain
uh to make to make sure that they meet a
constitutional uh U.S constitutional New
Hampshire constitutional and other rules
that are set up for districts
so you will see for instance uh let me
go back one of the the prime absolute
requirement when drawing districts is uh
deviation
okay the U.S Constitution is very very
very very clear and every time there's
been a case it it is the the main issue
that you have to conform to and that's
the one person one vote issue
um and the U.S Constitution has set that
an allowable deviation at 10 so in other
words when we draw draw Maps you try to
get minus five to plus five so you have
no more than a ten percent deviation if
you go over 10 percent deviation it's an
automatic go into court it's it's it's
found illegal
so for drawing Stratford County
um there are different ways to do it
the way this map is drawn actually is
with a total deviation you look at that
data sheet now on the upper left hand
side and you'll see the deviation total
for the for the county is 4.13 that's
extremely low that was the lowest uh
deviation I could come up with
um
and what were the other points I had on
that
okay
um yeah of course another big one they
have to be contiguous you know you can't
you can't for instance pair Durham with
uh New Durham they they have to touch
their border so when you're drawing the
maps they have to be contiguous
so
one of the questions I anticipate may
come up
is why couldn't you keep the cities
together in a County
two two responses to that one currently
you have an entire County that
encompasses everything so it's it's
you're kind of already doing that but
the main reason is there is no
possible way to draw
Stratford County Commissioners District
without taking Awards and combining them
with towns if you go to the upper right
hand corner of that data sheet I gave
you
that number there
I attempted to draw Maps keeping the
cities together the lowest
total County deviation I could come up
with and that anybody can come up with
and again I said 10 that's the maximum
you go into court you're going to lose
it it's just it's it's automatic
so you say well are there any other
counties like that yeah matter of fact
there are a lot of the counties that for
the state reps that we drew it's uh very
similar uh three or four counties we've
had to do that and in fact one of the
Commissioners districts Belknap County
also does that and again it's because
you have to keep your numbers within
that deviation range and
um bellnap includes for instance their
District three
they have Alton Barnstead Guilford
and Laconia Ward 2 only
and you have to drag that Ward 2 in
there to get the the numbers to balance
out in the in the county the one person
so I know there's a lot of other people
who are going to testify for this so I
will leave that at there I'd be happy to
answer any questions anybody has
thank you representative turcotte for
your bill introduction so I see some
hands for questions Representatives
Davis is acknowledged
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question it's a little bit
like the question I asked of the tax
assessor can you explain this to me like
I mean I'm kind of lost in the
statistics and I
think I understand
but I'm actually not sure I understand
so I need you know the the dummies
version sure which part of it which part
I I guess I guess the part of it
that you characterize as unfair yep
unfair in that for the last few decades
I think with the exception of one term
the county has elected uh three Democrat
Commissioners every time
in a county that is representative
the word is democratic not Democrat I'm
sorry to interrupt you
representative 11 you were not
acknowledged by the chair and please
please follow that rule
so anyway that's what you what you end
up is with it all Commissioners are
Democrats
in a democrat in a commit in a county
that is 60 percent Democrat 40 percent
Republican
so by going to like every other County
does where you have districts this would
the the data that I showed you on there
from uh 2022
it would have produced two Democrats
and one Republican
that's the fairness issue the fairness
issue that I spoke of is when we went
around to all the counties when we were
doing redistricting
was
at the time as you know it was a
republican-controlled house
and Time After Time After Time we heard
repetitively
we want fairness in the maps that that
are being drawn
that's the fairness issue
representative yokela is acknowledged
thank you and thank you for transporting
this committee to election law
um
the
um my question is
um how does this uh
law
go in why doesn't this law go into
effect in the next election and why does
it go in in 60 days and how is that
um going the bill
to be the bill itself takes effect 60
days but it would actually be on the
does it say that in the bill
I don't think it says that specifically
but that's the inference that you I mean
it's not the bill isn't there to take
the current Commissioners out of there
their current position it's going
forward
the chair recognizes representative
mangaputi
thank you madam chair thank you
representative turcott for taking my
question my question is fairness on
question of fairness
I come from Hillsborough County
and that's
when we are looking at Commissioners are
we looking at Commissioners or
republican or democrat or are the voters
electing Commissioners who have been
effective or what their platform is this
should be a non-partisan
representation so how would this make it
fair and
nonpartisan I think I've
explained that a couple times it says
the question is you have a and I I don't
know what your commissioner's situation
but if you elect at large three
individuals three commissioners
at large which means the entire County
votes on those three commissioners
and the county is 60 percent
Democrats and 40 percent Republicans
the result is going to be what I am
saying and what many people have
mentioned in the past an unfair result
of three Democrats being elected
it should be
if you're looking at
true fairness
if that's what we're going to go for
much like our House of Representatives
is 201 to 190 whatever at 7 or 98.
um I I don't think you can get much more
fair division of Democrats and
Republicans than that in our County it's
the only County where we re elect at
large if you go to what I've produced
here
based on the 2022 results you would end
up with two Democrat Commissioners and
one Republican
that to me is
Fair unfairness would be the ability
of a county with 40 percent Republicans
saddled with three
democrats for decades
follow-up Madam chair
I will not allow that at this time those
other Representatives that would like to
ask initial questions and I can Circle
back to you
representative Cahill is acknowledged
thank you madam chair thank you for
in the last say 10 elections do you know
how many Commissioners actually came
from this Northern District that you're
I'm probably not going to be able to
give you an answer I can give you an
answer in terms of
in the county the number of Republicans
that have been a republic a commission
and I believe it was one from Dover
years ago but other than that for
decades that there's been one
but it's specifically to that I no I
the chair recognizes representative
Gallagher
um
so
uh I'm just looking at the map and um
uh I'm noticing it gets
a very the second district gets very
narrow between the point of Madbury and
um the border with Rockingham County I'm
wondering if you could tell us what
exactly the distance is there at its
narrowest point
no I don't know the actual distance alls
I do know is they are contiguous and no
not different than uh some of the the
maps uh I'd have to think back about the
House of Representative Maps I'm I'm not
sure but the the rules for
redistricting or districting in this
case is that the towns and or the wards
have to be contiguous
look
yes
okay so on the topic of contiguity uh do
you believe that point contiguity
satisfies the contiguity Criterion
not only do I believe that but the uh
the district the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire has said that is the case
matter of fact
um that was a subject of the Manchester
2003 redistricting case there was a
point in Stratford County where that
happened that was between Stratford and
New Durham that also occurs in the
latest redistricting map in 20 that we
passed last year in this house the
map that was suggested by the Democrats
on our redistricting Committee in
Sullivan County in fact did that exact
same thing and yet so long long-winded
answer to your question but yeah that
has been found uh to be uh
okay in the U.S Supreme Court
uh in the New Hampshire Supreme Court
the chair recognizes representative
majority
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I I know in in my
history on this uh in this committee
we've had at least one representative
has tried to find consistency among the
counties for any number of different
issues and I'll apologize first for not
doing the homework that I should have
done and putting you on the spot for
this but
why in the current language is it except
for Stratford County that you do it this
way do we have the history of of why I
actually I didn't know but I I believe
you will hear I I think at one time uh
there's somebody who's going to test
another rep who's going to testify today
I think he may actually have the answer
for that I believe this the the history
is at one time it might have been all
counties were elected at large and over
the years
we've been I believe he will he'll back
me up on this I think it's been since
1979. we have been the only County like
this
I believe
the chair recognizes Representatives
Davis
I get how there are more Democrats than
Republicans
in a lot of these places
I don't get how that's not fair I mean
isn't it isn't it your job as
Republicans to convert Democrats to
Republicans and our job to do vice versa
I mean how how is it not fair that the
populations
just happen to be this way that's
politics
no well yes and no I mean if you want to
talk about by the district I would agree
with you absolutely but when you talk
about a county who elects at large in a
county that's 60 40. to me that's
anything but fair that's the actually
the opposite of the the term fair when
every other County does it
as you just said you know here's your
district there are Republicans and
Democrats that live in it here's a
district Republicans and Democrats live
in it
and we ended up for our state reps I
keep saying at 201 to 197.
this is a case and again I if you went
back and looked at the commissioner's
results and all the other counties I
don't know what the results was because
it wasn't a it wasn't a focus of mine
but I think you would find you wouldn't
find an argument from me on what you
just said the argument in this for
fairness is the county we do it as a
whole at large like no other County and
because the county as a whole without
districts is 60 40 we will not have any
Republican representation in the
commissioners
yes
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking this ball
so I'm trying why not just change it to
not at large I I didn't hear you the
question why not just change the
elections to not be at large wouldn't
yes and the only way to do that is to
have districts thank you
yes
the chair rep the chair recognizes
representative yokella
thank you
um
so
is there so there's in the Constitution
there is some requirement to try and get
um kind of as small as like each town is
able to have their own you know State
reps and stuff like that is there no
requirement uh for a county that it try
and be as as compact as possible and not
do what you know uh you know because
there's it wouldn't be allowed right now
to elect
the entire County delegation at large
right so is there's no such requirement
at the county level to be have a a
smaller uh District
I know you were you were a little bit
involved with the the the uh State Rep
so
38 Representatives into Stratford County
that's a lot more difficult to do to
make the numbers work and with districts
than it is
to come up with three representatives
does that make sense so no that although
there are that the main U.S
constitutional rule of
um you know that plus plus or minus five
percent ten percent is firm and if you
go over it you you always try to get
your
um deviation down as low as possible
because that tells you that the counties
are balanced as close to pot uh equal
population as possible but the the rules
and the
let's just say there when we when we
started redistricting we started with a
book that was this big by this big by
that thick with all the
um
legal rulings in the United States plus
we had things for New Hampshire
the majority of them were U.S House reps
and state reps because those are the
places where you're trying to compact
things into smaller this year I don't
even know if I remember seeing
a a case on commissioners
next the chair recognizes representative
Cahill
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking a second question
do you think it would be fair if say the
state representative from Dover was
really representing Milton and never
giving them people of Milton a voice
could you say that one again do you
think it would be fair if if
the representatives say representing
Dover w-3 ward 3
was was representing Milton at Large
absolutely not and that's the purpose of
this
the chair recognizes representative
mangaputi
thank you madam chair and this is a
follow-up to my question thank you for
recognizing me
um
you have
voters as Democrats and Republicans in
part of Republican Democrat and majority
of the middle is Undeclared you mean to
tell me that Stafford County has no
Undeclared voters
thank you for the question if you when I
was testifying I specified that these
numbers were the voting results from
2022 elections so I don't know
how many of the R's or D's in any of
those numbers I gave you are
Independence but that's irrelevant these
were the actual results of
the election of 2022. I put those there
for you to see so you could see what the
result of this map would have produced
can I have a follow-up mine yes you may
thank you so going this yes you cannot
stay Undeclared when you vote you can't
vote as an Undeclared I get it and this
is the voting record for 2022 but if
you're changing the map to elect
of a commissioner by District
and trying to base it on the voting
records of 21 election
you're not taking the demographics of
the voters
in a static non-election so how do you
predict it might change next 2024 there
might be more Republican on Undeclared
voting as Republican but to to be clear
when
when we drew or when I
Drew these commissioner's map
I didn't take into account
the results that I showed you on the
bottom of that right hand side of the
page I drew the district and then I said
okay one of the things they're going to
wonder when I present this bill is
how what would have been the results
coming out of the last election if this
map would have been
in place if we would have been electing
commissioners
by districts that's all those numbers do
I I'm not saying how many Democratic
democrat or republican or independent
voters there are and and that that's not
what I did I simply took the map I drew
and said here's what it would have come
out of that you would have had one
Republican who barely would have carried
and you would have had two Democrat
Commissioners that's all it is that's
all those numbers are
chair recognizes representative
Gilman
Madam chair and thank you for taking my
question this goes along the lines of
why not just do this for All Counties
and I agree that each County needs to be
delineated by which town they rep are
represented by Which counties being
represented separately but the first
half of the bill could be changed to All
Counties because there's only two this
is uh 653 colon one
comma 9 Roman numerals 6c
um
that can be changed to All Counties
because right now only Carol and
Sullivan if we make this change only
Carol and Sullivan would be the ones
that are elected at Large
no there's only one County right now
because we because we in 2020 the the
redistricting we drew All Counties with
commissioners
well right now it says what was the what
was the RSA 6 6 53 colon one elected for
two-year terms
and it says Carroll County one
County Commissioner from each County
Commissioner District by all voters of
so I'm just saying I'd have I'd have to
go back and look at that particular one
okay look at that in Sullivan
the chair recognizes representative
Gallagher
um yeah so
um going so kind of uh continuing on the
um theme of how count different counties
do things differently
so in Merrimack County
um the majority of our voters are
Democrats except um
and yet our accounting Commissioners the
way our districts are drawn um we have
two Republican County Commissioners and
one Democratic County Commissioner so
would you say that that meets your
Criterion of fairness between the
parties
I what I would say to that is I I don't
I'm not familiar with your particular
County but if it's if it has three
districts I would say yes that's fair
what I would say was not fair
is if you've got two Republicans and one
Democrat uh Commissioners in your County
right now my guess would be is if that
County elected their Commissioners at
large in other words you your entire
County elected
the three Commissioners like Stratford
does you'd have three Republican
commissioners
at this point the chair would like to
remind committee members that if you
would like to be acknowledged to speak
please raise your hand and try to obtain
my eye contact I do scan the committee
table from left to right and I try to
alternate and if you don't have your
hand raised and I don't see it then I do
not know that you would like to speak so
I did get some eye contact from
representative Tatro earlier so the
chair recognizes representative Tatro
first
thank you madam chair
I
I guess I'm looking at this rather
you've got the county of Stratford
everybody voted
for commissioners
and the Democrats came out on top
why would you try to negate
what the what the voters
have voted I mean how can you
we are not trying to negate what
happened in 2022 what we're trying to do
is going forward
our County elect Commissioners based on
districts like every other County
and by doing that you are not
disenfranchising 40 percent of our
counties
citizens
by when you only have 40 percent
kind of to Representatives Gallagher's
question in Reverse if it's a 60 40
split and you your county elects three
individuals by the county
and it's 60 40 you're going to end up
with whatever that 60 percent is whether
it's Democrats or Republicans that's
what happens in Stratford County it's
the only County where we do it so what
I'm what this bill would do is bring our
County in line with all the other
accountants
follow up
thank you
I
like you're trying to move things around
so that you end up so the Republicans
come out on top
no what it would do is it would
create
a county with two Democrat commissioners
and
one Republican commissioner instead of
three
and if if that's what the voters voted
why isn't that
good
the chair recognizes representative
trelelevin
am I to understand that you think a
republican never voted for a Democratic
candidate in the
County of Stratford in the state of New
Hampshire in the last 50 years
representative true 11 I would have no
idea if that's ever happened
follow-up Madam chair
yes you may follow up
sister Republican will automatically
vote for another person who is running
on the Republican ticket versus making
their own choice
as a republican to vote for the person
they think is best for the job whether
they be a Democrat or a Republican
I am not
um
making those hypothetical hypothetical
assumptions my assumptions are strictly
based on the data that's all it is well
all right I disagree with you
the chair recognizes representative
majority thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking one more question which I
think will be a quick and easy one on on
the page with the data yes sir and on
the lower right where it's County Wide
correct do I understand correctly that
is that is as is no districts drawn
that's what the total numbers are were
in 2022 correct and Madam chair one
quick follow-up for that yes you may
thank you do have do you happen to have
or can you tell me where I can get
history
on on what the election splits were sure
you can go to the Secretary of State's
website and look up each election
results that's where I drew that from
thank you okay appreciate it
the chair recognizes representative
lasalles
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
would you say that
the whole objective
of
non
at large districts
is to make people
feel that they have a franchise that
they're not disenfranchised and let me
expand on that a minute there are Parts
in this country where we have at large
elections by states
where if you're of the non-majority
party you have a feeling that your vote
doesn't count
do you see what I'm saying
I understand and that was part of one of
the I I think I've used that actual word
and part of my testimony about 40
percent or whatever the number is being
disenfranchised in our County in terms
of being able to elect uh a commissioner
thank you sure
are there any other questions from the
committee members for the prime sponsor
the chair recognizes Representatives
Davis
I think this will be a quick one
in your testimony you used you used the
phrase saddled with a Democrat
commissioner can you enlarge upon that
um our County other than like I said
other than
I think one term one individual that I
can think of in the last few decades has
been a republican so yeah we have had
I I think you'll get a flavor maybe for
that response um
there will be other individuals who will
be testifying today and they may might
are there any other questions
seeing none thank you for introducing
the bill representative turcotte thank
you
so next different different microphone
next the chair would like to acknowledge
um representative Michael Granger to
testify
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is representative
Michael Granger I represent Stratford
District Two that includes Rochester
Ward 5 Milton and Milton Mills it's a
small one we've got to include Milton
Mills this bill would separate Stratford
County into three separate districts uh
you may be wondering why this is
necessary
there are several reasons but the most
important by far is the simple reality
that the County Commission routinely
ignores people in the towns people in
the rural parts of Stratford County
should not be treated as second-class
voters and this legislation would fix
that
for example we had a recent Stratford
County delegation meeting we heard a
brief overview of the proposed budget
from the County Commissioners they
mentioned that all tax increases would
be below that of Rochester Somersworth
and dover's respective tax caps
when it was pointed out that Milton and
Middleton both have tax caps of their
own the response was and I quote oh I
didn't know that
end quote no further questions on the
matter were asked no inquiry into what
the tax cap in those towns even was just
a simple statement followed by a
continuation of what was apparently much
more important business
this isn't a one-off event it is very
clear to the people in my district as
well as among those who are nearby towns
that the county officials down south in
Dover don't even consider them at all
when it comes to decision making Dover
Rochester and Somersworth have priority
everywhere else is a tertiary thought I
have friends in the smaller towns down
south as well places like Barrington and
Farmington and Madbury and they report
the same thing
what we're proposing isn't new it isn't
radical it is precedented in every other
County in New Hampshire
I can get to your history questions as
well since 1979 it has only been
Stratford County that has had at-large
County Commissioners
opponents to this might point out that
Stratford county is the smallest county
in New Hampshire this may be true but
Belknap County which is a beautiful area
with wonderful people has only about 40
more square miles of land area and a
population of sixty three thousand seven
hundred and five that's less than half
the population of Stratford County and
it gets to have three separate districts
the gorgeous and remote kowas county has
a population of 31
268. there's about a quarter of the
population of Stratford County but it
has three districts
it's been over 40 years since Belknap
co-as and every other County decided
that the problems that are inherent in
having at large County Commissioners
were Troublesome enough to justify
legislation to fix it we've been dealing
with the same problems every other
County faced and it's high time we
finally did the same thing for Stratford
County
I urge you to vote OTP on HB 270 thank
you for your time I'd like to thank Mila
Patton and the legislative services for
helping with research on this and I am
thank you representative do we have any
questions the chair recognizes
representative mandraputi thank you
madam chair thank you representative for
taking my question so Stafford County is
the only County that's electing
Commissioners at Large
and uh you just said and there are two
other counties from our quick research
here says that there's two other that is
doing at Large
and
uh that's so the two counties that I
mentioned I brought up for two reasons
uh Belknap County I brought up because
it is in similar size to Stratford
County it's a little bit larger but a
lot of that is Lake and uh you know it
it is larger but it's only if you
actually only count land area it's only
40 square miles larger so it's basically
the same size in regards to livable area
um and this and it also has half the
population I brought up koas County
because koas county has as far as I know
the lowest population and it has three
uh three districts so both of those
counties that I mentioned they have
District uh voting for County
Commissioners uh follow Madame chair I
didn't get to my question ah yes you may
thank you so would it be considered Fair
after its District three districts in
Stratford County and yet voters elected
three Democrats
as Commissioners would it be considered
fair at that time I if if we broke it
into district and the voters chose three
Democrats then hey that's how that's
seeing none thank you for your testimony
do you have written testimony
um I do I it it wasn't part of my
written testimony so I skipped it but uh
I do you mind me answering some
do you have that written
um I have I have some revised statutes
from uh previous years if anyone is
interested in it um if we don't want to
take committee time on it I can provide
it yeah provide it by email okay thank
you
so next the chair would like to
recognize representative Cliff Newton
and um because we have a lot of people
wanting to testify and the time is 3 30.
I'm going to hold people to three
minutes so when you see me raise a pink
card that means you have about 30
seconds left
yeah
not going to happen
thank you thank you madam Vice chair and
thank you members of the committee uh
for the record my name is representative
Cliff Newton I representative Stratford
District sex I'm on my fifth year in
this honorable house and I haven't
testified since late 2010 or 2011. so
this is my lucky day I've got something
to say about this bill
first of all just forget about
uh Democrat Republican just wipe that
off your mind for a few minutes
Stratford county is made up of 10 towns
in three cities
uh
the approximate tax rate proportion
is the the three cities and Durham pay
22.7 million towards the tax bill for
the Stratford County
and the other nine towns pay 11 and a
half million so these four pay
uh two-thirds and the other nine pay
one-third
how did how that matters and where the
fairness comes in because this is at
Large
there are uh the Dover Somersworth in
Durham just those three two cities in
one town out of the 13
gave one party
eight thousand nine hundred and seventy
seven
more votes than the other party that's
two town to one town and two cities gave
them a cushion of nine thousand votes
now you add the city of Rochester to
that
in Rochester the old the question from
Rochester was 48 votes a 48 volt
difference between one party and the
other so what you've got is you've got
two cities in a town that are giving one
Party 9 000 votes cushion
in this County now you go to uh the
other towns the nine other towns and
they all matter because they're all part
of the county
you take the vote difference from one
part of the other or nine other towns
and it's a 60 volt difference
now that's mind-boggling what you've got
is you've got two cities in a town
providing nine thousand volt cushion to
who gets elected and the other towns
it's less than 100 volts
there is your unfairness
and there is why they run at large and
these people that run the commissioners
of the executive committee where the uh
the legislative committee and there's
three executive committee members per
each County
so that is the unfairness there so if
you're exact if you're a council a
commissioner and you know where your
bread is buttered with 9 000 votes
cushion who are you going to cater to
and that's what's happening here and I'm
going to tell you what I've seen and
this is what I've Vision what I've seen
and what I know
and I know that the other surrounding
towns which I'm not one of I'm Rochester
being treated very badly and ignored and
I'll give you a couple examples
one of the example is there's a what was
brought forward was a three-legged stool
and that was going to bring homeless
shelter to the city to the county it was
going to bring a new nursing home to the
county and it was going to bring a solar
farm to the county now
the homeless shelter was discussed with
Somersworth with Rochester and with
Dover
I don't believe any other County any of
the towns the Commissioners went to
those towns and talked to them about
this but there is a commissioner here
and if you want to ask him because I've
been trying to find out you want to ask
him what towns they've been to and what
dates of those meetings so I can
research it myself when they went to
every town and discussed that now
they again they went to Rochester
Somersworth and Dover now when they
talked about the new nursing home the
first proposal was 170 million dollars
and that had to be born that had to be
bonded we had to have a public hearing
for that bonding well guess what
one of the towns the state law says 21A
supplemental appropriation says the
clerk of the convention shall deliver or
mail to each member of the County
Convention will be in office on the date
of the convention vote in the proposed
supplement approach appropriation and to
the chairperson
of the board of Selectmen in each town
and the mayor in each City within the
county and to the Secretary of State a
statement including the amount of
proposed supplemental appropriation
meaning what you're going to have to pay
and the objects for which your money is
required the witness shall suspend can
you able to wrap this up
yeah I've got one page thank you so the
point is
the town of Farmington was never
notified
the secretary of state was never
you know they know they don't care about
these other towns
that's troubling is very often I've seen
I've witnessed it firsthand with the
other towns aren't even considered as
long as they take care of Nova
Somersworth
in in Rochester and Durham now the this
Commissioners and I know this because it
was in the paper that's the only way I
know because information is very
difficult to get from the county
the Commissioners at least the chair of
the commission went to
Rochester
he went to Dover he went to Somersworth
and he went to Durham and he gave a
presentation on the new nursing home and
what he was proposing I don't believe he
went to any of the other nine towns and
discussed with them what they were
proposing so this is the fairness this
is why we need to have a change is it
fair this bill absolutely is it is it
the right thing to do absolutely
and these are just a couple of examples
I've seen a lot more in the four years
that I've been there recently and I
apologize for talking loud but I'm hard
of hearing so I want to make sure
everybody can hear me and I think I've
had one page on this and my my
information came from the Secretary of
State's office and I will provide you
one copy of that and answer any
questions if you have any thank you
representative for your testimony does
the committee have questions for the
witness
seeing none thank you well thank you you
made it easy I just might testify again
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam chair and thank you
committee
I'm representative Burnham and I
represent District 2 which is Milton
Milton Mills I have to say that even
though as I'm part of the official name
but also Rochester Ward 5.
yeah
as a current chair of the Milton Board
of Selectmen and tax paying resident of
Milton for 27 years I have many reasons
why I think this bill should be voted
ought to pass
Milton and Milton Mills Villages are
combined as small as a small town of
4482 residents providing about
277 taxpayers
in March of 2020 the Milton voters
overwhelmingly voted in a petition
warrant article to Institute a two
percent tax cap in accordance with RSA
32-5
sensor 2021 budget our budget committee
and select board have worked endlessly
to honor our residents with reducing our
budget
returning 1.4 million dollars of
unassigned fund balance
through the reduction of our tax rate
while still maintaining our dra
recommendations of 5 to 16 percent of
our operating budget for unanticipated
emergencies
in 2021 Milton's County tax was in the
amount of 1 million two hundred three
thousand three hundred and sixty four
dollars which is about 21 of our
operating budget
to be added to our own tax rate
as Milton continued to streamline their
2022 budget
keeping under the two percent tax cap
during an inflationary fiscal year
the board and budget committee were
horrified to receive in October the new
County amount of 1 million four hundred
and fifty thousand seven hundred and
ninety seven dollars to be paid by
December 17 2022
this was an increase of 247
433 dollars or the rate of 21 more than
the previous year
this tax bill was three times higher
than any previous increase and placed
our town office on high alert
in the last days of our fiscal year
trying to set the tax rate getting it
approved by the dra and finally finally
issuing the tax bills to the residents
and homestead tax revenue would flow
quickly before the county tax payment
deadline
as a small town the select board are
fiscally responsible for the town budget
and retaining our staff with that budget
however with further increases proposed
by the Stratford County Commissioners
Milton and other small towns will be
forced to exceed their tax cap to offset
these proposed amounts which are set
after sb2 fiscal year budgets
that are voted in
how much should small towns anticipate
County tax increases when the county
does not honor small town tax caps
at a recent Stratford County delegation
public hearing and meeting
a commissioner had stated
for the 14th year in a row the proposed
budget is below the tax caps of three
Stratford County cities of Dover
Somersworth and Rochester
I personally asked the commissioner what
happened to the tax cap of Milton
and he answered that because of the
increase of value in Milton is why there
is an increase in the county tax amount
I'm not sure what type of financial
principles are used in this method
but I am certain it is not in the best
interest of Milton's residence
HB 270 gives Milton other small towns in
Stratford County an opportunity to have
a voice that speaks for them regardless
of party
and a face to which a voter can feel
confident in electing thank you for your
consideration
thank you representative other questions
seeing none I do have a copy if you'd
like for the record
next the chair would like to recognize
thank you chair and thank you for the
time to testify my name is
representative Kelly butenza I represent
Stratford District district 19. that's
Rochester's Awards one two three four
and six
so I'm a newly elected State Rep so all
of the stuff is is um is new for me so
everything from of course uh coming to
community hearings and and
um and being on a committee but also the
the state delegation so
um just in in kind of what I've what
I've witnessed and what you've already
heard this is really it has nothing to
do with party and um I was kind of upset
to hear that because if this changes
which every single other
County in the entire State and I have it
right here up on my phone it is only
Stratford County that is truly being
disenfranchised and if they all elect it
doesn't really matter who they elect
Democrat Republican it's it's really not
about that it's having representation
it's having a voice which was already
said and the example of the budget going
to that last delegation meeting it's
clear
the focus is on Dover Rochester in
Somersworth and all of these other towns
Barrington Durham Lee Middleton New
Durham Rollinsford Stratford Farmington
Madbury and Milton are left out in the
dust
that's clear
you can watch the zooms it's it's
Crystal Clear so the example of the
budget
um was also concerning because I didn't
know
um with tax caps and understanding that
and I don't think that we should be
bragging about how people aren't are you
know they're saving money or they're
going to be underneath but Rochester
every single person that I'm talking to
in my Wards is paying more in their
taxes so I'm not really sure and I'm not
an expert on the budget so hence why I
want
um you know five years to compare it to
so Eli I can be a good Steward for my
constituents and I think that's what we
want to be good stewards for our
constituents
so I strongly support this and I hope
that you all do as well this isn't about
party this is about exactly what's
happening in every other county in the
state
thank you representative for your
testimony the chair recognizes
and thank you for taking my question
so you said this is not about party
but the prime sponsor says it is about
party I'm confused
well I'm actually I don't think he meant
it that way I think he was talking about
representation so he's he's saying 60
40. if you look at Stratford County in
60 40 is 60 Democrat and Republican and
those are you know it that's party right
um but for example we have a we have an
election a special election coming up in
in Ward everybody knows about it right
in Ward four of Rochester right now his
name's David Walker the the leading
long-standing icon
um Democrat that's is actually sending
out a an endorsement letter for Mr
Walker because he's fiscally
conservative so I don't think it's about
that I think he was talking about
representation and unfortunately
sometimes when you're talking about
representation you have to talk about
party so I don't think that's his his
point he's basically saying that you've
got people that have that are voting a
certain way
um in certain towns that are not being
represented because it's an at large and
it is the only County of course in the
state
foreign further questions the chair
so if this truly isn't about party then
why is it that every single co-sponsor
and person who has representative who
has testified in favor of this bill
so far has been a republican like
couldn't you have at least found at
least one Democrat to go along with you
well to be honest I'm here today and
this is I don't want to say last minute
but it is I didn't I'm a brand new state
representative I'm brand new on the
delegation I don't even know
um representative
um I can't Patrol thank you you are on
our you are on our delegation but I
don't these are all new people to me so
um yeah if there was more time I'd be
I'd definitely be um talking to the
fellow Democrats and and having them
come here because it's everybody's voice
that should be heard it's not about
party
chair recognizes representative Cahill
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
representative Potenza
are you here representing the citizens
of Rochester are you here representing
the Republicans
I'm here representing the um exactly the
citizens of Rochester and Stratford
next the chair calls representative
thank you madam chair and
I'm welcoming myself back to my not
quite in it but Minnesota county used to
stop right there this was uh
Transportation or something I think I
served here for three years and sat well
it's all differently configured now uh
but uh but I've been on Edna for the
past 16 years
um and I am also
not coincidentally the chairman of the
Stratford County delegation so I see my
colleague representative turcotte I see
my colleague representative terlevan
representative Holland
and from Stratford County that is all of
you are my colleagues
but I'm here in opposition to 270
because uh I I it has some technical
problems that I that I think
um
can be can be avoided and I don't know
whether the committee has been informed
but there is an alternative out there
representative Holland I I sent you an
email with it I try to send it to
representative 11 as well uh some of you
I don't have your email addresses and I
was my brain was half over in Edna where
we were having executive session all
afternoon and I had to get back there so
I didn't think that I if I fooled around
with it I think I could have sent it to
the whole Municipal and County
government committee but but uh so I
think that the alternative is better
because as I understand it and I only
flew over it before I sent it off to the
two Representatives I named a moment ago
um uh the the
chairs uh Bill splits both Dover and
Rochester the two largest cities in
Stratford County
um and the alternative splits only
Somersworth which is not only the
smallest city but but considerably
smaller it's only about 11 000 people
whereas built over in Rochester are
about 33 000 people and that's one of
the realities in Stratford county is we
are a small County and area where the
fourth smallest fourth largest county in
in the state of New Hampshire
um and uh so a small County with the
population
very substantially centered in the three
cities of Dover Rochester and
Somersworth which are right side by side
and the reality is that
those those cities uh you know tophers
has all Democratic Representatives
sums with has all Democratic
Representatives Rochester has one at the
moment and possibly another one or not
depending on the outcome of the special
election that represented Potenza just
referred to a moment ago so the reality
is that we have
majority elections uh in this country
except for the presidential
contest which is you know
uh somewhat represented by the popular
vote or representative of the popular
vote but it's not a popular vote
um so the the fact that we have
a regularly three Democratic
Commissioners is a result of the fact
that
it's a democratic County over you know
regularly we don't have we didn't have a
no contest contest in this last election
there were three Republican candidates
running against the three Democratic
incumbents but we've had time after time
after time we've had no Republican run
for County Commissioner so of course and
but we have occasionally had Republicans
run and win
and so uh I I think that you know the
the county delegation has not
had any opportunity to look at this and
if they had I don't think we would have
you know only Republican Representatives
here to testify besides myself uh and I
I think that given the fact that these
this alternative plan that I've already
pointed out to you which I will
distribute as much as possible is it is
better for a fairer because the chair
represents turkot my friend my friend uh
uh is uh is uh is correct that all the
other counties
in the state of New Hampshire
have districts
but there's more than just a coincidence
in the fact that Rockham county is much
larger than Stratford County both in
size and in population to run
county-wide in Rockingham County or
Hillsborough County for that matter
would be ruinously expensive for a
commissioner and I'm sure they come have
to come up with a fair amount of money
just to run in their districts
representative can you you able to wrap
this up because you're well over you're
approaching six minutes okay I didn't
put down a Time Madam chair
but but I am the chairman of the
Stratford County and I have been for
over 10 years so I do have a strong uh
connection to the Stratford County and
the serving Stratford County and I want
to see that if we're going to have
districts I want to see that we have the
best plan if we're going to have a plan
at all so I'll be happy to answer end my
testimony and answer any questions that
I can
thank you representative Schmidt are
there questions yes the chair recognizes
representative mandaputi thank you madam
chair thank you representative Schmidt
for taking my question
um you would refer to Hillsborough
County to the two largest cities
Manchester and Nashua are in
Hillsborough County and we have 13 other
towns
but consistently we have had
all three Commissioners Republican
Commissioners does that make a
difference in terms of it's the voter's
Choice do you feel at large or
district-wise
it is the voter's choice and we are
honoring that do you think this uh at
large is not honor honoring the voter's
choice
well I I don't feel that I have the
necessary expertise I certainly don't
think I don't think that the commit that
our three Commissioners uh govern as
democrats for Democrats and and govern
as uh against Republicans they are
governing for the benefit of the
citizens of Stratford County in the
services that Trafford County provides
which are excellent uh and I think I
think that that's as close as I can come
further questions the chair represents
the chair recognizes representative
Cahill thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
I'm here if you have the best plan how
come you didn't share it with the whole
committee
I don't have your
your email address and the email address
that I had before I had to rush out to
go back to I got called back to my uh to
my voting on my executive session I had
representative Holland's email address
and representative Tre Levin's address
and I tried to get it in their hands so
that they could share it with you
there's nothing partisan about about the
email and if I'd thought about it I
could have sent it to the hill committee
okay
further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next the chair will recognize
ah thank you for letting me testify
today
um my name is James Connor I am a
representative of strep 19 which is five
Awards out of the six in Rochester uh
first term and I strongly agree with
this bill as to what has been stated
from
prior testimony
people in the northern part of our
County gets no representation in the
commissioner's office they might say
they do but they don't
the Commissioner's Office only you know
caters to a few towns or cities
that's it that's why they want their
money that's where they get it from
so
if we were if strep County was split up
into three and if the people voted in
three Democrats then well then we'd have
to live with it
okay that's what the people voted for
but you're based most of your votes
in Durham Dover and Somersworth that's
where they get their votes all the time
and I just saw the numbers and only one
of them would have won in Rochester
and not by much
and so I'm just gonna reiterate what
they just said that's all thank you
thank you representative does the
committee have questions chair
recognizes representative Cahill
thank you for taking my question
say there was a Democrat farmer from the
northern farmer area in your county
don't you think you would better
represent the farmers from that
and seeing none thank you for your
testimony
next the chair recognizes commissioner
Pappas
wait
thank you madam chair
I'll try not to be repetitious I'm Tony
Pappas commissioner from Hillsborough
County I represent
um to I represent Manchester and Two
Towns
I've also served in this legislature
many years ago and I enjoyed serving on
the Hillsborough County delegation for
many years and the executive committee
eventually becoming chair of the
Hillsborough County delegation and I've
been president of the New Hampshire
Association of counties
and I really feel privileged that I've
had the opportunity to participate and
to learn as much as I can about the
vital services that we County
Commissioners and all of the state
representatives provide to the citizens
of New Hampshire's 10 counties and as
you all know the counties differ from
one another and they organize themselves
in different ways and that's why I
oppose house bill 270.
I think Stratford County the state's
smallest county and we've talked about
this already geographically should
continue to elect Commissioners at large
I also think that redistricting should
occur only every 10 years in a
thoughtful way with some time to make
good decisions and I think the Supreme
Court has already ruled on this issue so
I recommend that maybe we should wait 10
years for the next redistricting before
applying this bill to Stratford County
so thank you for your consideration
please vote in expedient to legislate
for house bill 270.
thank you commissioner Pappas
um the chair recognizes Representatives
Davis
Madam chair and thank you for taking my
question
can you explain or account for
the anger that's been voiced here
on the part of certain citizens who feel
that they are not being represented to
you do you understand what that
oh I'm sorry
um
no I I don't I think you asked do I
understand it
um
I was I lost my train of thought what
I may have lost my train of thought too
but I hear some very strong feelings
being articulated in this debate
they don't come from nowhere they must
come from somewhere and I'm trying to
get a sense of what it's about
before you answer that the chair
the chair feels that that's an
inappropriate question because the
witness
has no idea why other people
testify or say what they say
well may I just say that I I feel that
County government should actually be
nonpartisan I never understood why we
had parties attached to our names for
County Commissioners is it's really very
very part non-partisan
and um
so Hillsborough County as one of the
representatives said has the state's two
largest cities and 27 towns and we all
seem to understand that each of us have
different issues
but it doesn't become a non- a partisan
kind of debate in Hillsborough County so
I have no idea why we're here today
the chair recognizes representative man
japoodi thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner Pappas for taking my
question you represent the largest city
and two small towns do
you get I mean you've served many terms
as a commissioner like you alluded to
do you feel like you are representing
the other two towns also where you have
the constituency or you just focused on
uh Manchester
oh I feel strongly that I represent
Manchester and Two Towns I love going
out to New Boston which is a beautiful
little New Hampshire town and I've met
many people there and made many friends
and I do understand that their issues
are different than the issues we have in
Manchester
Bedford also has has a whole different
kind of
culture and neighborhood
and different kinds of wants and needs
but we
I do my best to represent everyone and I
hope I do it successfully
further questions
follow-up yes you may thank you madam
chair uh one follow-up in terms of the
big cities providing a lot of social
services in the small towns unable to
provide that because of the small town
we have this conversation all the time
in our County
how does that balance out
because the revenue is generated by the
large cities to third one-third and
does that take your time share in terms
of being a commissioner
where you have to balance where the
revenue the services and how it affects
the neighboring towns
I think we do our best to provide the
services equally to all of our County
Citizens for example we have Meals on
Wheels which is funded by County
government not entirely of course
Meals on Wheels as a non-profit that
serves Manchester Nashua and all the
towns so there is there are many
examples of non-profit organizations
that are involved with County government
and other services that just apply
equally
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next the chair calls the commissioner
from Stratford County I apologize I
can't read the last name
foreign
it's red okay gotcha Madam chair members
of the committee my name is George
mclaris I'm chairman of the board of
County Commissions in Stratford County I
had the unique uh
honor of being elected by the people of
Stratford County recently to my 20th
term on the board of County
Commissioners
I've been there 40 years
prior to that I was in the legislature
in the 1970s I served on this committee
I'm also a former two-term mayor of the
city of Dover
I'm a former past president of the New
Hampshire Association of counties and
I've served
15 terms as chairman
of all the County Commissioners in our
state
and uh
I am not going to spend to waste your
time on many of the things that were
said today
first of all I think this bill should
have been in front of election law or
not this committee but be that as may I
don't mind coming back to my old
committee I served here in the 1970s
historically what has happened uh
with County governments is that the
county delegation would mean if there
was a concern regarding the election of
Commissioners or the creation of
commissioner districts historically the
county delegation would meet and have
those debates I've been through five of
these processes
five of them
the county delegation would meet they
would have a discussion and uh
they'd make a decision
now Chicago county is somewhat unique as
a long history of kind of being picked
on for lack of a better term but
uh shravagan is the smallest
geographically it definitely takes 25
minutes to get from one end to the other
although as the fourth most populous
County
in the state
historically what has happened is the
county delegation has met and had
determined on multiple occasions since
1940 that it was best to elect their
County Commissioners at large and there
were a number of reasons for that
I can go over some of them with you now
number one in order to to divide counted
the Stratford County up in the districts
you have to carve cities up
the cities were very very upset with
that the county delegations back then
didn't want to do that
uh and therefore that was one of the
major reasons why
that's uh number one number two it's
been represented to that the three
municipalities spend 60 percent of the
county budget which is which is pretty
close to being accurate
but this uh idea of uh that we do not
pay attention to the small towns or we
don't give any of them any uh deference
is just ridiculous
it's just ridiculous we're in a process
right now of spending three and a half
million dollars to upgrade their
dispatch services for all the towns the
county dispatches for all 10 Towns
we provide that Public Service uh to
those communities
also uh you've heard right now there's a
there's a political debate going on and
let me back up just for a minute about
the redistricting committee
the districting committee met in every
County I had a conversation with the
representative terracott and he talked
to me for about a 45-minute conversation
while this committee was looking at
districts across the state and he asked
me about what we should do about
Stratford County
I didn't I had mentioned to him that uh
the history of it and what happened as
I've mentioned to you
and uh I didn't think it was in The
public's long-term interest to divides
traffic County up in the in the
districts
and Beyond the cut the testimony that
you've heard here
I have served with Republican County
Commissioners
we've had sheriffs that were Republicans
I've had a county treasure that was a
republican he was there for 20 some odd
years had an opposition every year
always won the sheriffs were Republicans
I served with more Republican sheriffs
than I have with Democratic sheriffs
as an example
and those folks came from small towns
we had a Sheriff for 25 years it came
from Madbury probably the smallest town
in Stratford County
I've served with a republican County
Commissioner from the town of Stratford
I have more people living on my street
in Dover than they have in the whole
town of Stratford
so this idea that the the people had
disenfranchised
I I can tell you in my 20 terms there
I've been nominated by the Republican
in the past election which I thought was
going to be a strong Republican year and
you look back at all every 10 years we
have you know every 10 years we have a
strong Republican year here in New
Hampshire
I had opposition I was the top vote
Gunner
every Republican strong year I was the
top vote getter now if the people didn't
want me there because I'm the big bad
Boogeyman here in the room if the people
didn't want me they could have
opportunity to throw me out
but they haven't done that and I'm
hopeful that the reason why they haven't
done that is because I'm trying to do a
good job for the for all the people of
Stratford County
we don't act in a partisan matter on any
issue
as a matter of fact in the past 25 years
the county budget has been passed almost
with the unanimous vote by Democrats and
Republicans buying maybe one or two
votes in 25 years
the boats have been practically
unanimous
now recently uh recently
the county started a process of talking
about building a new nursing home and
there were some members of the of the of
the delegation who were against
construction of a new nursing home they
didn't want to give the county
commissions a blank check and I don't
blame them on that I can understand that
if you want to know where the anger is
coming from this is where the anger is
coming from some of them oppose the
construction or the expense of a new
kind of a new nursing home they say they
support the new nursing home but they're
upset about the expense and I get that
but
the uh
to divide the city of Dover and the City
of Rochester the two massive the two
major property taxpayers in the county
divide that in half and somehow think
you're going to gerrymander this thing
so that a republican gets elected
I suppose you have the power to do that
but the Supreme Court is ruled
on multiple occasions about the latest
occasion saying that you have to do that
once every 10 years
that window has passed
there are court cases on this in New
Hampshire
that basically say now read I'll read
from the case the latest case
Court ruled finally we held that once
the legislature has fulfilled this
constitutional obligation to reapportion
based upon a decennial census figures
it has no constitutional authority to
make another apportionment until the end
of the next federal census
this is our New Hampshire Supreme Court
ruled this
in a very similar case for this and
Canon and rocket out of Rockingham
County excuse me commissioner could are
the point being is that the Supreme
Court is recognized that
gerrymandering or adjusting adjusting
these districts uh based on who gets
elected every two years
is ill-advised
they don't think it's constitutional I
think you need to go through this pain
once let the dust settle you go for 10
years and you do it again
and I believe that this bill doesn't
will not meet constitutional muster it
doesn't make a difference how you divide
the county up because that window is
passed you want to do it nine years from
now you probably have the power to do it
but I think it's still advised
with that I'll answer any questions
does the committee have any questions
the chair rep recognizes representative
mandaputi
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um could you answer me in terms of the
voter registered voters what percentage
is democratic what percentage does
Republican do you have a large quantity
of independent voters the the larger the
largest portion of the voters in
Stratford County are independent
now we've had shifts
we had it goes back and forth we've had
times when the Republican party uh had
more registered voters uh it happened
when McCain Rafa president the
Republican party was much stronger at
the time
and then it then it should but it
shifted back and forth when I was first
on the county delegation 45 48 years ago
the delegation was a republican
delegation the county delegation
just to let you know additional
seeing none thank you commissioner for
your testimony thank you
next the chair recognizes Nicholas
Gamache
thank you madam chairman
uh I'm just a resident
I'm not an expert at anything you could
probably ask my wife
um
but I'm here from my name is Nicholas
kamash
and I'm from Milton New Hampshire
and uh as a resident of Stratford County
I'm frustrated to live in the only
County New Hampshire that has a uniquely
unfair method of electing County
Commissioners
the current at-large system does not
account for the voices and wishes of
many many of the citizens that live in
the smaller towns outside of the three
main cities of Rochester Somersworth and
Dover such as the town I live in Milton
there's no justification for such
discrepancy among counties within the
same state
fairness and representation for all
Stratford County residents should be the
utmost concern for house members
House Bill 270 will address this long
Injustice once and for all
I urge all house members to ask
themselves why Stratford county has a
different election Paradigm in votes to
make all New Hampshire counties equal at
last
thank you for your time
and I just like to say also that you
know I took time off work and drove over
an hour to be here because this is
important to me
um so thank you thank you Mr Gamache for
taking the time off and coming to
testify
so
with regards to the blue sheet for House
Bill 270 we have four individuals who
signed in as for the bill and two
opposing the the bill Madam chair point
of order
the remote sign-in was support to
approach pose 37
.
yes
um
and I totally understand if I may be out
of it can can we uh get oh thank you
thank you can we get clarification on
the uh the legality or the
constitutionality of being able to do
this okay all right thank you I
okay at this time the chair will close
thank you madam Vice chair for doing
that uh but the committee
we asked the gallery to be quiet until
we finish up please thank you
representative Newton
thank you we will see everybody tomorrow
morning at 10 30. we have uh I think
eight or ten bills we will be executing
and uh Republicans who are left in the
room we will be caucusing at 9 30.
oh